Bonsoir à tous.
Bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
pour ce dernier
rendez vous de cette année 2023.
On se retrouvera vers la mi janvier
avec Cédric
Villani qui animera
la première conférence de l'année 2024.
Mais je suis vraiment très heureuse
de terminer
cette saison
avec, avec Christophe Galfard.
On se connaît bien
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant.
Alors Christophe Galfard se présente
comme un écrivain scientifique
et je trouve que cette définition
lui correspond parfaitement.
Scientifique
qu'il est de par sa formation.
Je m'arrête vous m'arrêter jusqu'ici,
vous m'arrêter si je dis des bêtises.
Diplômé de Centrale Paris,
il part en 1999 pour faire l'équivalent
d'un master
deux à l'université de Cambridge,
dans le département des mathématiques
appliquées pour la physique théorique.
Un séjour prévu pour neuf mois
qui durera finalement six ans.
Je n'étais pas très bon en maths,
sauf que,
sortie dans les dix premiers,
il se voit automatiquement
proposer une bourse pour enchaîner
avec une thèse quand même, excusez du peu.
Et elle se fera sur les trous noirs
avec un directeur de thèse
qui porte un nom prestigieux,
un merveilleux personnage.
Je crois, nommé Stephen Hawking.
Héros, le héros de votre petite enfance ?
Je crois d'ailleurs.
En tout cas, c'est votre mère qui le dit.
Donc si c'est votre mère qui dit c'est
sûrement vrai.
Exactement.
C'était lié peut être à la lecture
d'un premier livre de Stephen Hawking.
Peut être, Je ne sais pas.
Apparemment, petit,
j'ai dit que je travaillerais plus tard
avec Stephen Hawking et c'était arrivé.
Alors cette thèse,
elle se fera sur les trous noirs
donc. Et
là, déjà,
dans cette relation avec Stephen Hawking,
il va arriver
l'écriture romanesque, en fait,
parce que vous allez
participer avec Stephen Hawking
et sa fille au premier tome
d'un livre qui s'intitule George
et les secrets de l'univers.
Romans pour la jeunesse,
qui explique que les lois du cosmos.
Après cette première expérience
d'écriture,
vous avez écrit seul des romans d'aventure
sur les questions climatiques
et l'avenir de notre planète.
Ça s'intitule Le Prince des nuages
et c'est
une trilogie qui est sortie en 2009.
Entre 2009 et 2013,
on n'a pas dit de bêtises pour le moment.
Oh, quel miracle !
On n'est pas habitué.
Les habitués ne sont pas habitués
à ce que j'ai déjà dit des bêtises.
Notre deuxième rencontre avec vous
aura lieu six mois
après la disparition de Stephen Hawking,
qui a profondément marqué votre vie,
je crois.
Christophe, vous lui rendre hommage ici
même à travers une conférence intitulée
Des trous noirs à l'origine de l'univers.
Et ce fut une très, très belle soirée
et enregistrée aussi
comme celle de ce soir
et qu'on peut donc revoir
sur le site de l'Espace des sciences.
Elle a eu un petit peu du 5 000 120.
C'était en 2018.
Mais avant cela, nous avons déjà eu des
rendez vous où nous avons été
très gâtés à l'Espace des sciences
grâce à votre goût pour la transmission
et le partage des connaissances.
Car dès 2015,
nous vous avons reçus pour un voyage
qui nous a permis
de remonter le temps vers le Big Bang.
Puis en 2017, pour
MC2, L'équation de tous les possibles.
Des conférences souvent liées
à la parution de livres.
Et puis, je rappelle
que celui intitulé
l'Univers à portée de main,
paru chez Flammarion,
a connu un succès fou.
Déclaré meilleur livre de science.
Il est paru en 2015.
Oui, c'est ça, c'est ça.
Et il a été vendu à combien
de millions d'exemplaires dans le monde ?
1 million, ça va.
Il a été traduit dans 25 langues.
Alors je vous souhaite
autant de succès à Christophe.
Je vous souhaite autant de succès
avec ce livre là.
Et votre actualité ?
On va en reparler dans dans un instant
après avoir précisé qu'en plus des livres,
il y a évidemment des conférences, nous,
on en a fait dans le monde entier.
Vous avez signé des chroniques
sur France Inter, beaucoup d'émissions
auxquelles vous participez
et puis aussi des documentaires.
Vous avez participé à celui de Davina
Bristow En quête d'une nouvelle terre
qui a été produit par la BBC
et en partenariat avec France 5.
Et puis dernièrement, j'ai eu la surprise
que j'allume ma télé 135
et je vois qui Christophe A.
Je le connais ce monsieur.
Pour une autre, un autre documentaire
qui s'intitule De l'autre côté de la lune,
un documentaire de François-Xavier Vives.
Je ne sais pas comment ils vivent,
qui est sorti en 2023.
Alors ce livre, je l'ai reçu hier.
C'était vraiment juste.
Tout juste tout juste.
Voyage vers l'infini.
l'Espace comme aucun humain
ne l'a jamais vu par l'auteur de l'Univers
à portée de main, qui est paru
aux éditions Michel Lafon en novembre.
En novembre dernier,
un très, très beau livre
qui a la particularité
d'avoir trois couvertures différentes.
Absolument.
Pour les petites histoires,
juste pour créer un cauchemar
chez des gens qui savent pas trop choisir
de créer des regrets à Candida,
un homme, J'aurais dû prendre l'autre.
En fait, il y a trois images différentes
qui correspondent
à trois choses différentes.
Je vous laisse déterminer ce que c'est
si vous voulez,
éventuellement, si vous voulez
les voir,
je vous dirai à quoi ça correspond.
Mais il y a une petite réponse
dans la conférence
que je vais vous donner tout à l'heure.
Alors je dois dire que j'ai un peu vécu
l'histoire de la création de ce livre
parce que, à l'époque déjà,
j'appelais Christophe en disant
ça fait longtemps, il faudrait revenir.
Voilà. Et il était débordé de travail.
En fait, au départ,
la proposition de la maison d'édition,
c'était bien d'écrire un beau livre
sur les images du nouveau télescope
James Webb,
celui qui a succédé à Hubble
et qui avait déjà fourni
depuis plus d'un an,
je crois, des images extraordinaires.
Même pas un an.
C'était un an émerveillement.
Contacté en mains.
Et après ?
Quand je l'ai recontacté en juillet,
c'était l'horreur.
Il était débordé. Pourquoi ?
C'est drôle ?
Parce que
je croise
l'éditrice dans la rue qui me dit
Mais Christophe, y a le phare.
Vous voulez pas écrire un livre
sur les images de James Webb ?
Je dis bien si, d'accord.
Je venais de faire une conférence
sur le sujet.
Je me suis bien parfait, je l'ai en tête.
C'est très bien et du coup,
je dis d'accord.
Et au départ, c'était parti
pour être un petit livre.
Sur les images qui ont commencé à paraître
le premier en juillet 2022.
Alors on est en mai 2023.
Ça faisait même pas un an en gros pour les
un an de James Webb.
C'est un livre sympa, Il y a des jolies
images, je me mets au travail,
je fais une sorte de narration
qui est tranquille.
Arrivent juin, juillet, août.
Tous les jours, il y a une nouvelle photo
qui est parue tous les jours.
Je me suis dit il avait fait exprès.
Du coup, je n'ai pas dormi de l'été,
je n'ai pas pris de vacances,
j'ai passé tout l'été.
À chaque fois,
j'avais une sorte de fresque que j'avais
envie de raconter et à chaque fois,
j'avais de nouvelles photos
qui arrivaient à moi.
J'étais fasciné.
C'était complètement ahurissant.
Le nombre de nouvelles photos
et de nouvelles découvertes
qui ont été faites.
Et du coup, au final, le livre
qui était censé être un petit voyage,
un petit carnet sympa,
c'est devenu une sorte de portrait
de l'histoire globale,
de tout notre univers tel
qu'on le comprend aujourd'hui.
Jusqu'à il y a avant hier, en gros,
jusqu'à avant hier.
C'est vraiment l'univers
tel que nous, humains
existant en 2023, ce qu'on en comprend.
Et du coup, je pouvais voir quelque chose
parce que c'est une particule héritée
quand même.
De ce livre là,
il y a quelques images qui se déplie
comme ça et dans lesquelles on peut voir.
Alors je ne sais pas ce que j'ai fait,
mais vous allez voir
comment on déchire une page,
voilà comment
on fait, comment et comment ça va
sûrement.
Et là, par exemple, merci.
C'est ça.
Là, par exemple,
on voit si j'ai bien compris.
On voit des images,
je suis perdu, je le vois à l'envers.
Ah oui, des images.
Je vous laisse vous dépêtrer.
Il me laisse emberlificoté
dans mes explications.
Des images prises par Hubble. Celles ci.
Exact, Bravo.
Et les mêmes prises par James Webb.
Et ça change beaucoup de choses.
C'est trop beau.
Franchement,
les images de l'univers telles
qu'elles nous arrivent aujourd'hui
sont juste folles
et je n'ai pas envie de dire maintenant
parce que je vais vous raconter
pendant la conférence.
Mais en gros,
James Webb, comme pas mal
d'autres télescopes qui existent
maintenant, nous montre un univers
qu'on n'avait jamais vu auparavant.
On lève des voiles, on découvre du nouveau
tout le temps, tous les jours.
C'est génial.
Et d'ailleurs,
dans les images que vous allez voir,
il nous a préparé des images
absolument formidables.
Il y en a même qui datent d'aujourd'hui.
On verra.
Mince, j'ai dévoilé quelque chose,
J'aurais peut être pas dû le faire.
Bon, en tout cas, on va découvrir tout ça.
Je vous préviens tout de suite,
la conférence sera sans doute
un peu plus longue que d'habitude.
On est parti sur 6 h, là où il faut,
mais ça vaut le coup
parce que c'est une nocturne.
On passe la nuit ensemble.
Il y aura des moments
où vous serez dans le noir total
pour bien profiter des images
qui vous seront projetées.
Merci.
Merci à toute l'équipe
qui a bien travaillé pour
pour préparer cette
cette projection aussi avec Christophe.
Et puis on se retrouve après.
On essaiera de prendre quand même
quelques questions
avant que Christophe aille
signer ses livres.
Pour ceux qui sont intéressés
auprès de la libraire
qui se trouve à l'étage au dessus.
Je suis sûr que vous allez passer
une très très belle soirée.
Une belle soirée parce que là, on va,
on va s'extraire de ce monde
un peu difficile pour rêver.
Et vu que la conférence est filmée
de manière
totalement naturelle,
n'hésitez pas à faire des oies.
Ah bon ?
Je n'avais pas prévu ça
ici, On se retrouve tout à l'heure.
Il y a déjà 450 personnes qui nous suivent
sur Internet pour cette conférence.
A tout à l'heure, merci.
Bon, alors je ne vais pas rester assis,
hein ?
Je vais me lever,
je vais vous faire une petite.
Un petit voyage ce soir
à travers toutes ces images
qui sont dans le livre
et qui viennent de paraître,
qui sont autour de nous et l'idée
dans ce qu'on va découvrir ensemble,
c'est d'essayer de comprendre un
comment on fait pour avoir ces images, de
pourquoi on a ces images,
pourquoi on envoyait des télescopes
dans telle direction et on va réaliser.
Ça va être le début de la conférence
que tout ce qu'on découvre en ce moment
est tout ce qu'on en voit.
Ce n'est pas par hasard, c'est
parce qu'on a transformé, il y a environ
100 ans, ou même un peu plus radicalement,
notre vision de la réalité.
Du coup, la conférence va avoir
en gros deux parties.
Une première partie qui va être théorique.
Et là, je sais que toutes et tous
qui êtes là dans cette salle,
Vous avez des connaissances de base
de la théorie quantique des champs
en espace courbe et donc on peut.
On peut se baser là dessus.
D'accord, comme peuvent l'être
directement, extrêmement loin.
À partir de là,
on ira explorer ce que cette théorie
nous permet de voir dans l'espace.
On va commencer par un petit
un petit exercice
que vous allez avoir à faire, vous ?
Je vais vous demander
pendant un instant de vous concentrer
et d'essayer de voir dans votre tête
l'univers tout entier.
Vous me dites quand vous y êtes,
vous essayez même sans blague, essayer
de mettre quelques étoiles comme vous
les imaginer des planètes, des galaxies.
Mettez en partout, mettez de la poussière,
essayez de vous représenter
réellement l'univers.
Si on vous demandait à quoi
reposait un enfant, on vous demandait
A quoi ressemble l'univers,
ce qui apparaît dans votre tête, c'est ça
que vous essayez de décrire plus tard ?
Je vais vous poser une ou deux questions
sur ce que vous voyez.
La première
chose, c'est est ce que vous y voyez
un bord
ou est ce que le bord est tellement loin
que vous le voyez pas ?
Vous avez peut être imaginé
qu'il y a un bord, mais il est loin.
Est ce que vous y voyez du temps ?
Est ce que vous avez mis
le temps à l'intérieur
ou est ce que vous avez considéré
qu'il existait peut être une horloge,
mais que cette horloge était extérieure
à cet univers que vous venez de voir ?
Très bien.
On a le droit de faire ça.
Donc les choses bougent
à l'intérieur de votre univers.
Et il y a une horloge à l'extérieur
qui fait un tic tac,
qui est donc le même pour tout le monde.
J'imagine que même la question des bords
vous voulez être posée ou non,
mais inconsciemment,
vous avez dit qu'il était là,
peut être extrêmement
loin, peut être à l'infini.
Mais vous le voyez quelque chose de figé
avec les choses qui bougent à l'intérieur.
Je pense que quasiment tout
le monde dans la salle le pense comme ça.
Notre univers, moi y compris,
c'est la vision
intuitive occidentale d'aujourd'hui.
Disons depuis quelque temps.
C'est comme ça
qu'on imagine notre univers.
En gros, l'univers que vous venez
que je viens de vous décrire,
je vous ai un peu
décrit ce que vous ne m'avez pas
dit, que vous aviez pensé,
mais en imaginant
que ce soit ce que vous ayez pensé un peu,
vous avez eu dans vos têtes l'univers
tel que Newton le voit,
cet univers avec ces étoiles
qui sont dans le ciel,
c'est ça qu'on va essayer de décrire
et de comprendre aujourd'hui.
Et on va partir avec cette Voie lactée.
Avec toutes ces choses qui sont là,
on va essayer de les comprendre
et on va partir
de cet univers que vous aviez
à l'instant dans la tête, qui est
l'univers de Newton.
Alors il y a quelque chose d'amusant
quand même dans cet univers là,
parce que je vous ai dit que c'était
notre vision occidentale aujourd'hui.
Mais est ce que ça a toujours été le cas ?
Pas vraiment.
Déjà, il y a une première chose
qui a eu lieu il y a quelques millénaires,
qui est que petit à petit,
des humains se sont rendu compte
qu'il existait
dans la nature des choses qui se répètent,
qu'il existe autour de nous
des choses
qu'on peut même prédire du style.
Je vous parie que demain matin,
le soleil se lèvera.
Et bien il se lève.
Tous les matins, les choses se répètent.
Si je lance un objet,
vous allez avoir dans votre tête
une image,
une intuition a priori de la trajectoire
de l'objet et de l'endroit
à peu près où il va tomber.
C'est obligatoire. On a tout ça en nous.
Si je lance quelque chose par là
bas à fond, personne va regarder là bas.
Si il tombe,
on regarde par la bas
parce qu'on a l'intuition
qu'il existe des lois dans la nature.
La recherche de ces lois, c'est ça qu'on
appelle la physique théorique.
C'est son but,
c'est de trouver des lois dans la nature
qui nous permettent
par exemple de prédire le futur.
Bon, c'est bien beau d'avoir ça comme
idée, mais comment est ce qu'on fait ?
Eh bien, les premiers chercheurs,
disons philosophes et
philosophes de la nature comme Aristote,
ont utilisé des mots pour essayer
de comprendre le monde qui nous entoure
et ils ont essayé de distinguer
ce qui pouvait être compréhensible
et ce qui ne l'était pas.
Aristote, par exemple, est arrivé
avec l'idée suivante qu'il existe
Si on regarde l'univers tout entier,
deux zones, il y en a une
qui correspond à tout ce qui est
sous la Lune et qui inclut la Terre.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle le monde sublunaire sous la Lune
et le monde au delà, au delà de la Lune.
Pour Aristote, ce qui était sous la Lune,
c'était le domaine des humains
qu'on pouvait potentiellement comprendre,
et au delà, c'était le domaine des dieux
sur lesquels on pouvait éventuellement
projeter des mythes et des histoires.
Mais on n'avait pas la prétention d'aller
y comprendre certaines lois.
C'étaient des lois des dieux,
ce n'étaient pas les lois des humains.
La personne
a ça appuyé dans ma poche
et personne ne me dit rien.
La personne qui a changé cette vision là,
c'est donc lui,
c'est Newton
Newton.
Il nous a donné un des plus beaux cadeaux
qu'on puisse offrir à l'humanité.
Il nous a donné le pouvoir
d'aller au delà de la Lune,
dans nos têtes, grâce à quoi ?
Grâce à une formule, grâce à une équation,
grâce à une loi que vous connaissez
toutes et tous, qui s'appelle la loi
de la gravitation universelle ?
Newton Ce qu'il a fait, c'est
qu'il a inventé un langage
qui n'était pas celui des mots,
mais qui était celui des mathématiques,
un langage mathématique qui permettait
de décrire le mouvement des objets.
Et grâce à ce langage là,
il pouvait faire des prédictions précises.
L'objet que je lance
on a sa loi de la gravitation
avec une force
qui attire l'objet vers le bas,
qui est proportionnelle
à la masse de la Terre à la distance.
Une certaine formule qui nous dit
et ça atterrira à cet endroit là
et on peut vérifier, ça marche.
Mais là où Newton a été extraordinaire,
ce n'est pas parce qu'il nous a dit
Il a compris la loi de la gravitation,
mais c'est parce
qu'il a rajouté le mot universel.
Il s'est dit que ce mouvement là
que j'arrive à prédire
pour mon objet sur terre,
il s'applique aussi à la Lune.
Autour de la Terre, il s'est applique
à la Terre, autour du Soleil.
Il s'applique aux autres planètes
autour du Soleil.
Il s'applique potentiellement
partout dans l'univers.
C'est la même loi qui existe ici sur Terre
qu'on
peut trouver,
qui s'applique dans l'univers tout entier.
Il a fait voler en éclats en une équation,
en une formule, en une loi,
la séparation qu'Aristote avait créée
entre le monde qui était sous la Lune
et le monde de l'au delà.
Alors je ne sais pas si vous imaginez tout
d'un coup
à quel point l'imaginaire humain
a eu un coup de frais.
Avant,
on était cantonné à ce qui se passait
sous la lune et soudain,
on avait accès à tout.
On avait accès à l'univers
tout entier dans nos têtes.
Pour l'imaginaire, c'était fou.
Et c'est à partir de là
qu'on a pu vérifier.
Parce que c'est bien beau
de dire que ça marche, que ma gravitation
est géniale à l'universel.
On a pu vérifier grâce aux observations
de plein d'astronomes,
si effectivement
cette loi fonctionnait ou non.
Alors à l'époque,
ça a été gardé pour les planètes
qui étaient connues à l'époque de Newton
et il y avait la Terre, Vénus, Mars,
Saturne
et Jupiter, Jupiter et Saturne. Mais
pas longtemps après, il y a
un scientifique qui s'appelle Herschel,
dont on reparlera encore tout à l'heure,
qui, en observant le ciel, a
vu, a découvert une autre planète,
une planète que personne ne connaissait
encore, qui s'appelle Uranus et Uranus.
Elle avait cette particularité
qu'elle ne tournait pas exactement
autour du soleil, à la manière de Newton.
Il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas.
Alors quand ça arrive, ça, en science,
on a deux choix soit on se dit la théorie.
Finalement, n'était pas si bonne,
soit on se dit Ah ben, la théorie en fait
été correcte, mais il y a quelque chose
qui vient perturber notre trajectoire.
Il y a une autre force
qui vient s'appliquer
et qui fait que
ça ne tourne pas comme prévu.
Deux scientifiques en particulier
se sont attaqués
au problème de la trajectoire d'Uranus
et ils se sont dit
que pour que ça colle
aux prédictions de Newton,
il fallait qu'il
y ait encore une autre planète,
une planète plus loin encore, et que rien
que sa présence gravitationnelle
attirant Uranus devrait suffire
à expliquer la trajectoire bizarre
qu'on voyait dans le ciel.
Grâce à ça, ils ont pu prédire
si cette planète existe vraiment
ou on devrait la trouver dans le ciel.
Ils ont regardé dans le ciel à tel moment,
à tel endroit,
comme prédit, et ils ont trouvé Neptune.
C'est grâce à une trajectoire
qui n'était pas comme celle de
que Newton avait prédit
qu'on a découvert une nouvelle planète.
Alors là, non seulement on s'est dit
que Newton avait bon, mais on s'est dit
que quand même, c'est cool,
il se passe un truc.
On a réussi à découvrir une vraie loi
universelle dans notre univers.
Ce qui est amusant,
c'est qu'il
y avait un problème avec Mercure aussi.
Mercure
ne tournait pas non plus autour du Soleil
comme Newton l'avait prédit,
et Mercure est plus proche du Soleil.
Alors imaginez le nombre de scientifiques
qui se sont dit
Je vais chercher une autre planète
aux alentours, je vais devenir super connu
moi aussi parce que je vais trouver
une planète à côté qui n'a jamais été vue
et elle a été cherchée pendant 180 ans
cette planète.
Et figurez vous
qu'elle n'a pas été trouvée,
ce qui est une très bonne chose
car elle n'existe pas, il n'y en a pas.
Il y a un réel problème
avec la trajectoire de Mercure.
Elle ne tourne pas autour du soleil,
exactement comme Newton l'avait prédit.
Alors si vous demandez
mais comment on peut voir un truc pareil,
ça veut dire quoi ? Pas
tourner autour du soleil comme prédit ?
Comme prévu,
vous pouvez imaginer une trajectoire
en forme d'ellipse, une sorte d'œuf
dans le
ciel avec les mouvements qui sont partout.
L'œuf lui même,
il va tourner autour du soleil.
Ça, c'est prédit par Newton aussi.
Une trajectoire,
ça fait quelque chose comme ça en gros,
mais ça tourne très doucement.
La différence entre
ce qui avait été vu pour Newton,
ce qui avait été calculé par Newton
et ce qui avait été vu, c'est un léger
mouvement de contorsions de cet œuf
qui était même minuscule, de l'ordre
d'un degré
sur 500 ans, mais qui avait été détecté
par des astronomes.
Et en général,
quand il y a des petits trucs comme ça
qu'on n'arrive
pas à expliquer, c'est qu'il
y a quelque chose de profond derrière.
Il a fallu attendre 180 ans
pour avoir une réponse à la question
de ce qui vient perturber pourquoi Mercure
ne tourne pas autour du Soleil
comme Newton l'avait prédit.
Alors,
comment on fait pour faire ça ? En fait,
comment un
scientifique va dire
comment attaquer le problème de Mercure ?
La question qui a été posée est
la suivante c'est quoi la gravitation ?
Parce que certes, Newton
nous a donné une formule,
mais il nous a pas dit
ce que c'était que la gravitation.
Il nous a donné un modèle,
un truc à calculer,
mais pas d'explication de la gravitation.
Je vous propose qu'on cherche ensemble
comment résoudre ce problème.
Si quelqu'un veut monter sur scène,
ça m'étonne pas que toi t'es en vie,
mais je vais vous donner quelques indices.
Quand on est face à un problème comme ça,
on a le droit d'imaginer ce qu'on veut.
Donc on peut se dire, par exemple,
qu'on reprend l'univers
que vous aviez dans la tête
tout à l'heure.
Reprenez votre univers de Newton,
que vous aviez
gigantesque, avec des étoiles
et tout partout.
Maintenant, vous enlevez tout,
vraiment tout.
Il n'y a plus rien.
Donc vous l'avez dans la tête, il y avait
l'univers, maintenant il est vidé.
Et dites vous bien pourquoi est ce qu'il
ne resterait pas
quelque chose dans cet univers vide ?
Pourquoi il n'y aurait pas un tissu
qui remplit tout,
une sorte de fluide invisible
qui serait là ?
On peut imaginer ce qu'on veut.
On a dit donc imaginons ça.
Vous aviez votre univers ou la vidéo,
mais on ne peut pas vraiment le vider
parce qu'il y a quelque chose qui reste,
qui une sorte de tissu.
Eh bien, si je remets une étoile
à l'intérieur de cet univers vidéo
et qu'il y a un tissu
et mais on peut dire que l'étoile
va interagir avec le tissu, par exemple
en le courbant.
Alors si c'était un tissu plat courbé
et comme ça.
Mais c'est un tissu qui remplit tout ça.
La courbe dans le sol courbe
dans toutes les directions,
partout autour de autour de autour de lui.
Maintenant, si on remet une planète à côté
genre Mercure
et qu'on la lance à côté,
l'espace est en courbé
et la planète va tourner autour
en suivant la courbe
créée par cette étoile
dans le tissu de notre univers.
Alors,
la personne qui a essayé de faire ça
se les représentait de manière
mathématique, le plus simplement possible.
Donc imaginons qu'on ait notre tissu
qui est comme ça, qu'on ait notre étoile
avec Mercure par dessus, avec des courbes.
À chaque fois, on lance, ça fait un tour,
on regarde quelle est cette trajectoire.
Et pour toutes les planètes, on retrouve
exactement ce qu'avait prédit Newton.
Et pour Mercure,
on trouve celles qu'on voit dans le ciel.
C'est à dire la correction à Newton
apparaît automatiquement.
Donc là, on se dit il y a quand même
quelque chose d'intéressant à nouveau.
On peut peut être aller au delà de Newton
et comprendre ce qu'est la gravitation.
Alors, je vous l'ai dit,
ce fluide qui serait tout
autour, ce tissu,
ce n'est pas quelque chose de plat.
Si on veut avoir une vision
un peu plus réaliste de ce à quoi ce tissu
ressemblerait, il faut qu'on l'imagine
dans toutes les directions
qui entourent l'étoile et qu'il est courbé
dans toutes les directions aussi.
Donc, ça donnerait plutôt une image
qui ressemble à celle ci.
C'est un peu psychédélique, sympa.
L'idée, ce serait donc
le soleil,
la terre, tous les astres qui existent
dans notre univers courbe
ce tissu de notre univers.
Vous allez me dire oui, c'est bien, tu es
bien sympa avec ton histoire de tissus,
mais on le verrait là
si on tombait quelque part.
Je ne sais pas quoi, on le sentirait.
Eh bien,
c'est exactement ce que vous sentez là
maintenant, sur vos chaises,
si vous n'êtes pas en train de vous
envoler,
si vous voulez,
à chaque fois que vous essayez de sauter,
vous retombez vers le sol.
C'est parce que vous glissez le long de
la pente dans l'espace que crée la terre.
Il n'y a pas de plastique sous vos pieds.
Il n'y a pas d'aimant
qui vous retient au sol.
Il y a cette pente dans l'espace
qui vous fait glisser
et le fait que vous ne voyez pas plus.
C'est parce qu'il
y a votre chaise, c'est parce qu'il
y a le sol qui stoppe votre chute.
Pardon,
vous ?
Vous aviez l'impression de tomber ?
C'est peut être ça. En fait.
Une fois qu'on se les dit, on peut
le ressentir dans son corps qu'on est.
C'est notre corps en entier
qui tombe vers le bas.
C'est pas juste un point au milieu
qui est attiré.
Maintenant, revenons en au temps
parce que pour que les trajectoires soient
bonnes, ce n'est pas
que l'espace qui doit être courbé,
c'est le temps aussi.
Alors ça, qu'est ce que ça veut dire
tout à l'heure dans l'univers
qu'on a imaginé ensemble de Newton,
l'horloge était à l'extérieur.
Là, la vision de la personne
qui a eu cette idée,
c'était de remettre
l'horloge à l'intérieur de notre univers
et d'en mettre une à chacun des points,
à chacun des points.
Là, dans la pièce, il y a une horloge
à chacun des points dans l'espace,
il y a une horloge
à chacun des points de l'univers,
et elles n'ont pas toutes le même tic tac.
Ça va dépendre de ce qui est à côté
le tic tac d'une montre qui est là
où tu vas à la surface de la terre
ne va pas être
le même que celui d'une montre
qui est dans la station spatiale
en orbite autour de la Terre.
Ça ne va pas être
le même que celui qui est d'une horloge
qui est à côté du soleil.
Ça va être différent à chaque fois.
Et cet univers
dans lequel vous allez avoir l'espace
et une horloge à chaque endroit,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'espace temps,
Ce tissu qui est là, il est fait
d'espace et de temps, c'est l'espace temps
et c'est lui
qui est courbé par l'existence des objets.
Alors, avant de voir ce que ça signifie,
parce que c'est ça qu'on va explorer
ensuite, je vous propose,
J'ai trouvé comme par hasard
une photo de l'illustre inconnu
qui a eu qui a fait cette théorie.
Le voici,
c'est Albert Einstein.
C'est lui qui a eu cette idée
d'espace temps
courbé par les objets
qui sont à l'intérieur.
Et ce que je vous ai décrit à l'instant,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la relativité
générale d'Einstein, C'est son,
c'est sa théorie de la gravitation.
C'est
très joli et vu, vous êtes très fort.
Je me suis dit que j'allais
vous montrer des équations,
il y en a plusieurs aujourd'hui.
Voici la première.
C'est l'équation de la relativité générale
d'Einstein.
Alors c'est là que tu peux monter
si tu veux nous l'expliquer.
On est.
Alors
je vais vous l'expliquer, cette équation,
parce que je trouve ça marrant d'expliquer
de temps en temps quelques équations.
On commence par un truc facile.
D'accord, on a un signe égal.
Si jamais vous ne savez pas
ce que c'est, on est mal, mais c'est lui.
Il y a un côté à gauche
du signe égal
et un petit côté à droite du signe égal.
Est ce que jusqu'ici
tout le monde suit bien
à gauche ?
Il y a plein de petits signes.
Globalement, ce que le côté gauche
signifie, c'est de la géométrie.
C'est justement ces courbes
dans un espace temps,
dans une sorte d'univers,
c'est les trajectoires courbées
que peut prendre la lumière
en passant d'un endroit à un autre.
C'est ça, ce sont les collines
et les courbes d'un univers.
C'est de la géométrie, ça.
À droite, le ça, c'est des constantes
et le T qui est là, c'est de l'énergie,
c'est l'énergie qui est contenue
dans une étoile, l'énergie
qui est contenue
dans une planète, l'énergie
qui est contenue dans l'air,
dans un rayon de lumière.
Donc tout ce que vous voulez,
c'est de l'énergie.
Donc ce que dit cette équation,
c'est que la géométrie est égale.
C'est ça à l'énergie
géométrie égale énergie.
Personne n'y avait pensé auparavant,
vu que auparavant la géométrie,
il n'y avait rien, c'était tout plat,
ça n'interagissent pas,
ça ne pouvait pas changer.
Là, oui.
Si vous changez l'énergie,
vous changez la géométrie
sur l'image qu'on a eue tout à l'heure,
ça veut dire que le côté gauche,
c'est la géométrie, ce sont les courbes
et le côté droit, c'est
l'énergie, c'est l'étoile.
C'est ce que vous voulez,
c'est tout ce qu'il y a autour de vous.
C'est pas si compliqué
cette équation là.
C'est une des plus belles
qui existent dans tout le petit
panier de lois de la physique
qu'on est aujourd'hui.
C'est
une loi qui est quand même pas longue.
Là, je l'ai écrit en gros, mais en gros,
ça tient là dedans.
Ça décrit tous les univers possibles
et imaginables, ça écrit notre univers,
ça décrit la façon dont l'espace se courbe
autour du soleil,
Ça décrit la trajectoire des planètes
autour du Soleil, ça décrit absolument
tout ce qui a à voir avec la gravitation
dans notre univers tout entier.
Une petite équation qui décrit tout ça.
Bon, ok, ça marche pour les planètes, mais
est ce que ça marche pour autre chose ?
Est ce qu'on a d'autres moyens de vérifier
qu'effectivement
l'univers est courbé comme ça
autour des autour des étoiles ?
Et bien si on se dit ah bien
je vais lancer un rayon lumineux
qui va aller vers le soleil.
Si l'espace est courbé, il y a des chances
que le rayon lumineux y soit dévié
sans même toucher le soleil,
juste en passant à côté.
Et c'est une prédiction de la théorie.
La théorie dit si c'est
si l'espace, c'est vraiment comme ça,
si j'ai le soleil dans le ciel le jour,
et bien les étoiles qui sont loin derrière
vont être déviées
par le passage du soleil
comme une lentille qui viendrait
déformer les étoiles qui sont au loin.
Alors on a qu'à pour vérifier
cette théorie, on a plus qu'à regarder
les étoiles qui sont autour du soleil
quand le soleil passe à côté
et voir si elles bougent à son passage,
comme si on passait
une lentille déformante dans le ciel.
Alors pour ça, on a un problème,
c'est que le soleil
le jour, il est beaucoup trop puissant,
donc on voit absolument pas
les étoiles qui sont autour.
Même pas la peine d'essayer.
Et quand on essaye la nuit,
eh bien le soleil il est pas là.
Donc ça ne marche pas.
Einstein nous a donné sa formule
en 1915 et en 1919.
Quelque chose de spécial est arrivé
une éclipse, une éclipse du soleil.
Le soleil était dans le ciel,
la Lune est passée devant, a
complètement bloqué la lumière du soleil.
Du coup, on pouvait voir les étoiles
qui étaient autour
et on a pu prédire où elle serait.
Selon Newton, où elle serait,
selon Einstein
et la personne qui s'est dit
Je vais vérifier tout ça.
C'est un astronome, un astrophysicien
anglais qui s'appelle Eddington
et que voici
et qui s'est dit exactement ça.
Il s'est dit que si la lumière
était bien courbée par le soleil,
alors cette étoile, c'est la vraie.
Sa lumière vient vers nous,
elle est déviée par le soleil,
elle nous arrive et nous,
on a l'impression qu'elle est là.
Et bien ce décalage, on peut le calculer
et on peut vérifier pendant l'éclipse
s'il a bien s'il a bel
et bien le lieu pour les étoiles
qui sont autour du soleil.
Voici un des clichés des Hinton
et les petits points.
Les petits ronds, vous voyez partout,
sont les endroits où que vous voyez. Là,
un peu partout sont les endroits
où des étoiles sont apparues et
dont la position avait été calculée
et prédite.
Et toutes étaient là où Einstein l'avait
prédit et non pas Newton.
Le soleil en
passant dans le ciel courbe l'espace
et le temps qui sont autour de lui
et dévie la lumière qui est autour.
Pas mal.
Ça a fait complètement changer d'avis
tout le monde sur Einstein,
sur la gravitation surtout.
Le New York Times a publié les en une,
La théorie d'Einstein triomphe
et un journaliste un peu flatteur
est allé voir Eddington en lui disant Mais
professeur, comment avez vous fait ?
La théorie
d'Einstein est tellement compliquée
qui paraît il n'y a que trois personnes
sur terre qui la comprennent.
C'est génial !
Bravo et Eddington,
après un moment de silence
paraît il, l'a regardé et a dit
Il y a Einstein et moi.
C'est qui la troisième personne ?
On vous parlait ?
À partir de là,
notre vision de l'univers
a complètement changé.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que l'univers que vous aviez
dans votre tête
tout à l'heure, qui était statique,
qu'on avait vu au départ, dans lequel
il y avait toutes les étoiles, et cetera
Il était tout plat, il était indépendant
des planètes et des étoiles
qui étaient dedans, ce qui que même
si les planètes peuvent vivre et mourir,
même si les étoiles peuvent vivre
et mourir et se déplacer,
l'univers qu'on s'imagine dans nos têtes
au départ, lui, ne change pas.
Il est là depuis toujours
et pour toujours.
Ce n'est pas ce que dit
Einstein à Einstein.
Il nous dit que notre univers,
il interagit
avec les choses qui sont dedans.
Donc il peut changer.
Et s'il peut changer, c'est
qu'il peut avoir une histoire.
Et s'il peut avoir une histoire,
c'est qu'il a peut être un début.
À partir de là, une quête a
commencé dans la communauté scientifique,
philosophique, humaine
qui est la recherche de ses débuts
et la tentative de comprendre
l'histoire de notre univers tout entier.
Alors je vous montre en teaser
un petit peu
une image
qui date de l'année dernière
et qui a besoin
d'absolument tout ce que je viens
de vous raconter pour être comprise.
Là, vous avez une image de ce qu'on
appelle un champ profond
les champs profonds.
Pour les télescopes, c'est
quand on prend un télescope surpuissant
qu'on lui demande de regarder
un endroit minuscule dans lequel
on veut voir rien entre les étoiles.
Dans la nuit, qu'on le laisse pointer
dans cette direction pendant des heures
et des heures, parfois pendant des jours,
parfois pendant des semaines,
qu'on récolte le plus de lumière possible
et qu'on se dit
et qu'on essaye de
d'apercevoir ce qui n'était pas recevable.
Je ne sais même
pas si c'est un mot un peu recevable.
Ça, c'est à peu près la taille
d'une tête d'épingle tenu à bout de bras.
Il y a des dizaines de milliers
de galaxies à l'intérieur de cette image
qui est un des champs profonds
du télescope spatial James Webb,
dont je vais vous parler très bientôt.
Sur cette image, il y a des objets
qui sont un peu étranges,
notamment à droite.
Là, ce qui va apparaître maintenant,
la virgule, ça s'appelle
l'hameçon.
Ce petit truc là s'appelle l'hameçon.
En fait, c'est une galaxie.
Ce qui se passe là, c'est qu'il
y a une galaxie un peu blanche,
un peu nébuleuse au centre,
qui est entre nous
et l'autre qui est beaucoup plus loin
et une autre qui est beaucoup plus loin.
Si nous, on est là,
il y a une galaxie qui est ici
et il y en a
une autre qui est vraiment loin derrière.
Et la lumière de la galaxie
qui est derrière vient vers nous
en passant à côté de la galaxie
qui est au milieu,
qui va dévier sa lumière et déformer
l'image de la galaxie lointaine.
Ça donne ça.
C'est une vraie photo d'une
galaxie déformée par une autre galaxie.
C'est ce qu'on voit dans le ciel.
Alors ce qui est amusant, c'est
qu'on ne peut voir ça que depuis la Terre,
parce que ce n'est que depuis la Terre
qu'il y a un alignement
de ces trois galaxies.
Ici, on était ailleurs dans l'univers,
on verrait pas cet hameçon,
on verrait juste l'autre galaxie telle
qu'elle est.
Spirale ou jolie,
ou je ne sais pas quoi vous en train
d'être formé, loin, loin, loin derrière.
Mieux encore, grâce à cette idée
que l'univers
peut être déformé, l'espace
et le temps peuvent être déformés.
Vous pouvez avoir une fois de plus
il y a la Terre ici, une galaxie, là
une autre galaxie.
Ici, la lumière peut passer
éventuellement par dessus.
Il peut être dévié et revenir vers nous
par dessous, être dévié
et revenir vers nous sur les côtés.
Et du coup, depuis la Terre,
grâce à la galaxie du milieu,
on peut voir plusieurs images
distinctes des points différents
de la galaxie lointaine.
Mieux encore, parfois,
les trajectoires ne sont pas les mêmes
en distance.
Du coup, la lumière
va prendre plus de temps pour aller
d'une certaine galaxie à la Terre
qu'un autre chemin.
Ce qui fait que vous allez voir
plusieurs images d'une même galaxie
lointaine à des moments
différents de sa vie en même temps.
C'est comme si, de très, très loin
dans l'espace, on regardait quelqu'un
regarder la terre et vous voyez là
maintenant, ça, c'est pas possible.
Mais imaginons maintenant
comme vous étiez quand vous étiez bébé
et comme vos grands parents étaient
au moment où ils ont fait vos parents,
vous n'étiez même pas encore nés
et on voit ça ensemble
en même temps, dans l'espace.
Bizarre,
mais il se trouve qu'on le voit,
donc on sait que c'est vrai.
Du coup,
la question qui se pose maintenant,
c'est très bien d'avoir toutes ces images.
Mais c'est quoi cette lumière
qui nous parvient du lointain ?
De quoi elle est faite, cette lumière
qui nous permet de voir les étoiles.
Quand je vous ai demandé une fois de plus
d'avoir cette vision de l'univers
dans votre tête, vous aviez des points
lumineux, peut être partout
qui apparaissaient, des étoiles,
des choses qui émettent une certaine
lumière, qui font que notre univers
n'est pas complètement obscur.
Eh bien, je vous propose maintenant
qu'on a vu ce qu'est l'espace temps.
Maintenant
qu'on a vu le contenant de notre univers,
de nous interroger sur ce qu'est
la lumière elle même.
C'est la deuxième partie théorique
de ce début de conférence.
Cette lumière qui est là,
qui est autour de nous, c'est quoi ?
Étonnamment, un des premiers à avoir fait
des expériences
sur la lumière à nouveau,
c'est Newton Newton.
Il s'est interrogé sur ce
qu'était la lumière blanche,
ce qui était les couleurs, ce qui était,
ces choses que nos yeux perçoivent.
Il a créé, il a trouvé un petit, il a fait
un petit trou dans un mur de sa maison.
Il a laissé passer un filet de lumière
qu'il est allé jusque dans un prisme
et qui a créé cet arc en ciel.
Donc il s'est dit OK, la lumière blanche
est faite de lumière colorée.
Les couleurs que nos yeux perçoivent
sont une partie de la lumière blanche.
OK, parfait.
Les années passent,
les gens s'interrogent de plus en plus.
À tel point que, au final,
certains scientifiques se disent
Mais si ça se trouve, ces couleurs
qu'on voit autour de nous,
elles vont avoir
des propriétés particulières.
À tel point que début du XIXᵉ siècle,
à la fin du 18ᵉ début XIXᵉ siècle,
les scientifiques
se sont dit que si ça se trouve,
les couleurs en elles mêmes
avaient des propriétés thérapeutiques,
qu'elles étaient capables
de soigner des maladies et qu'un savant
mélange de couleurs permettrait
de soigner n'importe quelle maladie.
Il y a un scientifique en particulier
qui s'est posé la question des propriétés
des couleurs.
Dans ce sens là, c'est Herschel,
celui dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure,
qui a découvert Uranus et Herschel.
Il s'est dit Qu'est ce que je peux faire
pour analyser la lumière ?
On est en 1800,
il n'y a pas énormément de techniques
et de technologies à sa disposition.
Donc il s'est dit la première chose que
je vais regarder par rapport à la lumière
et par rapport aux couleurs,
c'est si elles n'ont pas éventuellement
la même température les unes des autres.
Alors il a fait le même dispositif
que Newton.
C'est lui, Herschel,
et il a pris son arc en ciel.
Il a mis un thermomètre dessus
sur sa table et il a vu que le bleu violet
est moins chaud
que vert jaune,
qui était moins chaud que l'orange,
qui était moins chaud que le rouge
quand on allait de gauche à droite.
Sur l'arc en ciel,
la température changeait.
Alors là, il était très content.
Il s'est dit J'ai trouvé un truc,
je vais déjeuner pour ça.
Pour fêter ça, il va déjeuner, il revient
et en revenant, il remarque que le soleil
ayant bougé dehors,
forcément son arc en ciel,
il s'est un peu déplacé sur la table.
Et le thermomètre,
il est plus au niveau du rouge.
Il est dans le noir
à droite, du rouge par là,
à côté
de l'arc en ciel, il va pour le ranger.
Il remarque quoi ?
Que le noir à côté du rouge
est un degré plus chaud que le rouge.
Alors il se dit Oh,
il se passe un truc,
ça signifie qu'il y a forcément ment
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Une onde qui arrive
et qui vient taper sur ce noir,
sur le thermomètre qui est dans le noir.
Il y a là
une lumière invisible à nos yeux,
mais une lumière qui chauffe
le thermomètre.
Alors ça, vous savez toutes et tous
qu'elle existe,
cette chaleur là, cette température là.
Imaginez une bûche dans la cheminée
qui a cessé de brûler.
Les braises se sont un peu refroidies.
Elles ne sont plus rouges,
elles ne sont plus brillantes,
mais vous pouvez encore
approcher votre main et vous allez sentir
la chaleur.
N'allez rien voir,
mais vous allez sentir la chaleur.
Du coup, Herschel s'est dit
Ce sont des ondes de chaleur
qui sont à droite du rouge.
Pas mal comme découverte
et vous pouvez essayer chez vous.
Vous prenez un arc en ciel
quelque part qui viendrait du soleil,
vous mettez un thermomètre,
vous allez voir au delà du rouge.
C'est plus chaud que dans le rouge.
C'était en 1800.
L'année d'après,
il y a un autre scientifique
qui s'appelle Ritter, qui s'est dit
Je vais essayer de faire la même chose
de l'autre
côté de l'arc en ciel, dans le violet.
Alors j'ai trouvé une super photo de Rita.
C'est lui.
Je trouve que ça,
c'est assez à son avantage
et il s'est dit pareil.
Est ce qu'il y a une température
plus basse dans le violet ?
Alors là, ce n'était pas probant,
alors il a essayé autre chose.
Il s'est dit
Je vais tester avec une substance
qu'on appelle le chlorure d'argent.
On connaît le chlorure d'argent
parce que c'est ce qui,
sur les plaques photo, c'est une substance
qui noircit en présence de lumière.
Et bien il a mis cette substance
à gauche du violet
et il a essayé de voir
si elle noircissait.
On la refait avec un trombone,
ça donne ça.
C'est pas lui.
C'est le chlorure d'argent
qui est posé sur un trombone qui noircit.
Et quand on enlève le trombone,
on voit qu'il y a une ombre.
Donc il y a vraiment quelque chose qui est
venu taper sur le chlorure d'argent.
Au delà du violet.
Alors aujourd'hui, ça a un nom.
C'est
ces ondes qui sont à droite et à gauche,
celle qui est à droite du rouge.
On l'appelle l'infrarouge,
celle qui est à gauche du violet,
on l'appelle l'ultraviolet.
Herschel a découvert l'infrarouge en 1800,
héritèrent,
a découvert,
a découvert l'ultraviolet en 1801.
Bon, pas mal.
On découvre qu'il y a des choses au delà
de ce qui est visible.
Très bien.
On s'en doutait un peu,
mais là, c'est confirmé.
Maintenant,
est ce qu'on peut unifier tout ça,
donner un sens global
à toutes ces ondes qui sont partout ?
Et bien, pendant 70 ans,
les gens ont même pas essayé en vrai.
Ils ne se sont pas posé la question
jusqu'en 1870 à peu près.
Et le travail d'un scientifique
s'appelle James
Clerk Maxwell, que voici
à l'époque de Maxwell,
ce qui était à la mode en physique,
c'était l'électrique et le magnétisme.
L'électricité,
vous savez toutes et tous que c'est
ce qui passe dans les fils électriques
et le magnétisme.
Vous le savez aussi.
C'est ce qui fait qu'un aimant,
en effet, sur les clous et sur d'autres
choses, c'est le magnétisme.
Et que Maxwell voulait essayer de faire,
c'était de faire pour l'électricité
et le magnétisme,
ce que Newton avait fait
pour la gravitation,
à savoir trouver un langage mathématique
qui décrit leur comportement.
Parce que sinon, on reste avec des mots
et on ne va pas
forcément aussi loin que Newton
a été avec la gravitation.
Donc c'est dit.
Est ce qu'on peut trouver des formules ?
Et il en a trouvé 18 Et quelques années
plus tard, il y a un mathématicien
qui s'appelle Heaviside,
qui les a réunis en quatre équations.
Et vu que vous aimez
ça, je vous les ai donné.
Voilà les quatre équations
dite de Maxwell, même si ce n'est pas lui
qui les a toutes trouvées, c'est lui
qui les a unifiées
grâce à Heaviside aussi.
Alors je vous les explique
celles là aussi rapidement.
Et eux, c'est l'électricité
B et H, c'est le magnétisme.
Afin que vous ayez un peu de mémoire
et d'électricité.
BH C'est magnétisme.
Maintenant, il y a d'autres petits signes
un peu bizarre dans ces équations.
Il y a ce truc là là, le triangle
qui est là, là et qu'on appelle Nabila.
Alors Nabila, c'est quoi ?
C'est quelque chose qui nous dit
que si on a une sorte de sphère
et bien dans un cas,
le Nabila du haut avec un point à côté,
ça nous dit ce qui se passe
quand la sphère s'agrandit.
Mais un tout petit peu,
on prend un tout petit peu plus de place
et celui du avec le foie ou le X à côté,
c'est
quand la tord en gros twist
sans forcément l'agrandir.
Mais on va la twister.
Et est ce que ça crée des changements
quand on fait ça ?
Et bien on voit si on regarde
les deux dernières images que oui,
là il y a un truc bizarre.
Là le disque est pas droit.
Vous voulez que je vous dise
comme on l'a appelé
des ronds ?
Ça ça se lit des ronds sur des ronds.
Et ce truc là,
ça veut dire c'est la variation de B
du champ magnétique dans le temps.
On va rester que sur cette équation
elle dit quoi ?
Elle dit que la variable
que si le champ magnétique, un aimant
varie dans le temps,
eh bien ça crée un champ électrique.
Ceci dit, comme ça,
avec cette petite équation toute petite
et ridicule, vous avez la base de toutes
les centrales électriques de la planète.
Toutes les centrales
qui existent aujourd'hui font un truc
elles trouvent un moyen de faire tourner
un aimant
soit grâce à de l'eau
qui va couler dans un barrage
et qui va faire tourner une turbine
qui va faire tourner un aimant,
soit en faisant une centrale nucléaire
où il y a une réaction radioactive
qui va chauffer de l'eau
qui va devenir vapeur et en étant vapeur,
qui va faire tourner une turbine
qui va faire tourner un aimant
et cet aimant tourne,
crée de l'électricité.
On met un fil pour récolter
cette électricité qui va jusqu'à chez vous
et vous pouvez faire griller votre pain.
En gros,
les équations qui sont là disent
qu'on c'est en faisant tourner un aimant.
Comment fabriquer un grille
pain, C'est ultra puissant.
Toutes les éoliennes,
toutes les centrales électriques
de la planète dépendent de ça.
Quatre petites équations ridicules,
mais Maxwell, il ne s'est pas arrêté là.
Maxwell Il s'est dit OK à chaque fois
et quand il y a de l'électricité,
il y a du magnétique et cetera Mais
est ce que je pourrais
séparer les deux ?
Cela dit, j'ai oublié de vous dire
une chose importante.
Là, vous voyez qu'il
y a électricité et magnétisme
dans la même ligne égale entre les deux.
Ce qui veut dire que ce qui était
jusqu'à présent d'un côté
l'électricité et de l'autre
côté du magnétisme sont réunis
en quelque chose que vous connaissez,
qui s'appelle l'électromagnétisme.
C'est Maxwell, grâce à ses équations,
a inventé l'électromagnétisme,
montrant que l'électricité et magnétisme
ne sont que deux aspects
d'une même chose
qu'on appelle l'électromagnétisme. Bon,
très bien, on a l'électromagnétisme
et maintenant est ce qu'on peut voir
comment éventuellement l'électricité
va se propager
dans l'espace avec la télécommande ?
Là, si je la lance, Newton nous disait
comment elle va bouger dans le temps
et où elle va tomber sans faire appel
à un autre objet qui viendrait.
Donc est ce qu'on pourrait savoir
comment l'électricité évolue dans le temps
sans faire appel au magnétisme ?
Maxwell Il a joué avec ses équations
et il a trouvé ça.
Ça, c'est
une équation où on a l'électricité
qui change dans le temps
par rapport à l'électricité.
Cette équation, qu'on la comprenne ou pas,
ce n'est pas grave.
Ce qu'elle a d'extraordinaire, c'est
que tous les scientifiques la connaissent.
Tous les scientifiques de l'époque
la connaissaient déjà.
C'est une équation qui est qui apparaît
dans énormément de domaines des sciences.
Si, par exemple, je veux voir comment se
propage une vague à la surface de l'océan,
eh bien c'est cette équation.
Au lieu d'avoir heu, on a levé pour vagues
qui va apparaître.
Elle a disparu
là, voilà
une vague à la surface de l'océan
se propage comme ça
et la vitesse de la vague,
c'est le petit cv qui est là.
Si on prend le son dans la salle
qui vient jusqu'à vos oreilles
et qu'on va savoir comment le son
se propage.
C'est exactement la même équation
avec le son
qui se propage à la vitesse du son
qui est là.
Cette équation
s'appelle une équation d'onde.
C'est comme ça que se propagent
toutes les ondes dans la nature,
quelle qu'elle soit, que ce soit
une vague, que ce soit du son, que soit
ce que vous voulez.
Maxwell a montré
que l'électricité
se propageait comme une onde.
Donc l'électricité est une onde.
Mais comme l'électricité et magnétisme
sont tous les deux ensemble.
C'est que l'onde électromagnétique existe.
Il y a une onde électromagnétique
qui se propage.
Et alors, à quelle vitesse ?
Eh bien c'est ce truc qui est là,
le petit c
qui est là, que Maxwell a mesuré
et il a vu que c'était
la vitesse de la lumière.
Il venait de découvrir que cette lumière
qui nous permet de regarder les étoiles
depuis l'origine des temps, qui nous
permet de nous voir les uns les autres,
est une onde électro magnétique
qui se propage dans l'espace.
Alors ça, c'était pratique
parce que tout d'un coup,
on comprenait ce qu'était la lumière
grâce à ça, une onde.
Alors on peut voir l'arc en ciel
et se demander quelle est
la différence entre le bleu et le jaune
et ou le rouge, ce que vous voulez.
Eh bien, la seule différence, c'est
la seule différence qu'il existe
entre deux ondes,
c'est la distance entre les crêtes.
Si les crêtes sont rapprochées,
on est vers le bleu, vers le violet.
Si les crêtes sont écartées,
on est vers le rouge,
mais du coup, on
pourrait encore écarter plus les ondes
au delà du rouge.
Et c'est dire
que ça ne s'arrête pas au rouge
et que ça continue aussi vers le violet
grâce aux ondes
électromagnétiques de Maxwell.
On a compris
qu'il existait énormément plus de lumière
que ce que nos yeux, nos yeux,
que celle que nos yeux perçoivent.
On a la lumière visible
qui est tout l'arc en ciel
qui est incertaine,
qui correspond à des ondes,
qu'il y a une certaine distance
entre les crêtes et il y a d'autres ondes
au delà du visible dans le rouge
qui sont l'infrarouge de Herschel.
Ensuite, les rayons,
les ondes micro-ondes et les ondes radio.
De l'autre côté du violet,
il y a l'ultraviolet.
Il y a les rayons X et les rayons
les plus énergétiques de tous qui
sont les rayons gamma.
Là, soudain, on a
une vision globale
de la lumière dans l'univers.
Et ça, elle veut dire quoi cette vision ?
Elle veut dire que quand vous voyez un arc
en ciel dans le ciel un jour de pluie,
le soleil est bien.
En fait, il existe un autre arc en ciel
après le rouge, un autre après le bleu
qui sont faits de lumière que nos yeux
ne perçoivent pas, mais qui sont là.
Il y a des arcs en ciel
qui remplissent le ciel tout entier.
Alors il y a encore une image
qui est apparue
avant que je ne veuille vous la montrer.
Ce monsieur a du coup fait une expérience
parce que l'idée est de savoir est
ce que le monde est différent lorsqu'on
le regarde avec des ondes différentes ?
Bon ben, il y a un exemple en particulier
qu'on peut comprendre facilement.
C'est imaginez qu'au
lieu de regarder le monde
en lumière visible comme vous le faites là
maintenant,
imaginez qu'on regarderait le monde.
On regardait le monde en rayons X en bas.
Là, vous verriez un squelette
en train de vous parler et moi, je verrais
une assemblée de squelettes devant moi.
On aurait une expérience
très différente de la soirée
si on voyait en revanche le monde
en infrarouge.
Bien, c'est ce qu'on voit là.
Là, c'est une photo
d'un scientifique en lumière visible
et c'est exactement la même photo
qui va apparaître à côté en infrarouge.
Ça donne ça.
Elle ne veut pas obéir,
ça donne ça.
C'est exactement
la même photo au même moment.
Ce qui veut dire que si vous voyez
là en infrarouge, je verrais votre tête.
La chaleur de vos têtes en plus prononcé
que la partie de vos corps
qui est couverte
par des couverte par des vêtements
et qui apparaîtrait un peu plus sombre.
Mais en tout cas, on voit sur cette image
là quelque chose d'extraordinaire.
On comprend soudain
qu'après plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'années de tentatives
de comprendre le monde
qui est autour de nous, que grâce au fait
qu'on a réalisé
que l'électricité magnétisme
était deux facettes d'électrodes
de l'électromagnétisme.
De toutes ces équations qu'on a réussi
à trouver petit à petit avec
génération après génération,
l'humanité a enfin réussi
et je pense que c'est le point
culminant de toute notre évolution
à regarder à travers un sac plastique
qui ?
Il y en a qui ont
suivi par rapport au début, je vois,
les autres sont subjugués.
Mais vous, vous avez bien suivi.
On peut voir à travers un sac plastique,
avec la lumière infrarouge,
la lumière infrarouge.
Ce que ça a dit cette photo, c'est
qu'elle peut nous permet de voir
à travers la matière.
Il y a certaines choses
qui sont transparentes à la lumière
infrarouge, mais qui bloquent la lumière
que nos yeux perçoivent.
Et bien imaginez maintenant
qu'au lieu de pointer votre appareil
photo en infra rouge vers un sac plastique
et un monsieur,
on la pointe, on le pointe vers l'espace
et que là, soudain,
on a accès à un univers dans lequel,
potentiellement,
on voit à travers la poussière.
Ce serait pas mal,
ce serait plutôt réussi.
C'est une des raisons pour laquelle
on a construit le télescope
James Webb,
qui voit l'univers en infrarouge.
Il le regarde en infrarouge
pour voir à travers la poussière
et pour d'autres aspects
que je vais vous montrer tout à l'heure.
On a fini la partie
théorique,
donc je vous la résume rapidement.
Ça vous fait,
Je vous la résume rapidement en un,
on sait maintenant ce qu'est
la gravitation
la gravitation, c'est que l'espace
et le temps sont courbés autour
des objets, que notre univers va évoluer,
qui va changer,
qui va dévier
les passages de rayons lumineux.
Donc, si on veut regarder
des choses lointaines dans l'espace,
on va comprendre qu'il
y a des trajectoires étranges
et ça va nous permettre d'avoir
une interprétation des images qu'on a.
Et on sait aussi qu'on peut capter
plein de lumière
différentes qui vont nous donner
des aspects différents de l'univers.
De la même manière
que si on regardait en rayons X,
on serait tous des squelettes
en infrarouge.
Vous verriez des choses comme ça
à travers des sacs plastiques
et les ondes de chaleur.
Et on a plein de facettes différentes
de notre univers qui apparaît.
Alors, avant
d'aller sur James Webb,
je vais vous répondre à une question
plus générale sur tous les autres
télescopes, surtout les télescopes.
C'est que vous êtes peut être posé.
Pourquoi on envoie des télescopes
dans l'espace ?
Pourquoi est ce qu'on les met
pas tous à la surface de la terre
pour regarder le ciel
et regarder les étoiles ?
Pourquoi se prendre la tête
à en envoyer loin
dans des fusées
alors qu'on pourrait faire tout ça ici
un jour montre un graphisme
dont je suis assez fier,
C'est lui.
Merci.
Là, vous avez la terre en bas,
en gris,
c'est le ciel et l'épaisseur du gris
correspond en gros à l'opacité du ciel.
C'est à dire que si c'est tout plein
comme à gauche, la lumière passe pas.
Si c'est ouvert comme à droite du milieu,
là, c'est que la lumière passe.
Et en haut,
vous avez toutes les différentes longueurs
d'onde, les différentes couleurs
qui vont arriver, quand les longueurs,
quand la lumière a des oui
qui sont rapprochées, c'est des rayons
ultra énergétiques
comme les rayons gamma, les rayons X.
Là, vous avez les rayons X
gamma X, là, vous avez des ultraviolet
et vous avez Hubble qui capte
un peu l'ultraviolet,
la lumière visible et un peu après.
Là, vous avez James Webb qui capte
en infrarouge et d'autres qui sont là.
Mais on voit que
toute cette partie là du ciel
est complètement opaque.
À toutes ces lumières qui viennent ici.
C'est à dire que si vous voulez regarder
dans l'espace, en rayons X ou en rayons
gamma ou en ultraviolet, en gros,
il faut sortir de l'atmosphère de la Terre
parce que tout est bloqué par le ciel.
Ça n'arrive jamais au sol,
tout est arrêté.
On ne voit pas le reste de l'univers
en rayons X, gamma, ultraviolet.
Du tout. On le voit rien.
Depuis le le sol, la seule partie
qui est un peu transparente,
c'est par ici.
Il y a la lumière visible avec l'arc
en ciel qui est en gros absorbée
un peu moins de la moitié par le ciel,
mais qui arrive à traverser un peu.
C'est pour ça
qu'on a envoyé Hubble dans l'espace,
parce que ça permet de voir en visible
la totalité de la lumière
qui nous vient de là.
Au Et James Webb, pareil.
On l'a mis dans l'espace, notamment
parce qu'il
y a une partie des
infrarouges qui passe pas.
Je vais
revenir là dessus dans deux secondes
et en ondes radio, en revanche,
le ciel est complètement transparent.
C'est pour ça
qu'on a des télescopes gigantesques,
des télescopes de radio gigantesques
comme Arecibo qui est dans le James Bond.
Je sais pas si vous l'avez vu,
mais qui est kaputt
parce que le truc qui est tombé, ça
tout casser, il ne marche plus.
Mais il y en a
un nouveau qui a été fabriqué en Chine,
qui s'appelle Face, qui fait 500 mètres
de large de diamètre et colossal.
Et ça, ça marche
très bien à la surface de la terre
parce que le ciel est transparent.
James Webb Il est particulier,
Il est particulier parce qu'il
capte ces ondes de chaleur,
ces ondes infrarouges,
pour pouvoir capter des zones de chaleur,
des zones infrarouges, il faut être
au froid.
Il faut
être à pour James Webb
à moins de 133 degrés.
Donc il y a des énormes boucliers
qui bloquent la lumière du soleil.
Et pour qu'il
ne soit pas perturbé par la chaleur
de notre planète de la Terre,
on l'a mis extrêmement loin.
Pour vous donner une idée des distances.
Si la Terre est comme ça,
à peu près à Bâle,
que Voici
est à environ 400 kilomètres
de hauteur d'altitude,
c'est un peu comme la station spatiale.
Quand Pesquet va dans l'espace,
il monte dans la Station spatiale
internationale qui est à environ 400
kilomètres de hauteur.
C'est moins loin que Lyon,
mais c'est vers le haut
et du coup, c'est compliqué.
Et on voit que déjà,
à cette distance là, l'univers
commence à devenir extrêmement hostile.
La lune, là, on est à 400 kilomètres.
La lune, c'est
à 300 000 kilomètres de la Terre.
Donc ça commence
à être beaucoup plus loin.
James Webb
est pas à 400 kilomètres,
il n'est pas à 300 000 kilomètres.
Il est à 1,5
million de kilomètres de la Terre
et il a été posté à un endroit du ciel
très particulier, très précis.
Un endroit de l'espace
qui pour lequel les forces
gravitationnelles, les courbes dans
l'espace et du temps créé par le Soleil
et créé par la Terre s'annulent.
On a le soleil qui est là,
la terre qui est là.
James Webb,
qui est bien à certains endroits,
qui est tel que lorsque la Terre tourne
autour du Soleil, James Webb
reste exactement au même endroit
par rapport à la Terre, il suit la Terre
sans avoir besoin
de lui mettre du carburant.
Donc c'est très, c'est très pratique.
Ça s'appelle un point de Lagrange.
James Webb, c'est lui.
Hubble arrive à voir
l'univers en lumière visible.
Je vais vous montrer une ou deux images
bientôt.
James Webb regarde l'univers en infrarouge
et comme maintenant,
on va partir sur les images
parce qu'on a terminé la théorie.
Vous allez voir qu'il y a trois raisons
pour lesquelles on a fabriqué le télescope
James Webb dans l'espace et qu'on l'a
envoyé dans l'espace et à chaque fois,
c'est pour répondre à des interrogations
qui sont un peu différentes
et en taille.
Le miroir de Hubble,
c'est à peu près un miroir de James Webb
qui est quand même beaucoup plus gros,
beaucoup plus précis.
Voilà, j'espère
que vous avez survécu à la théorie.
Maintenant,
je vous propose de partir ensemble
dans un voyage vers l'univers lointain.
Grâce à toutes ces images là.
Donc on va revenir sur notre petite
image de départ, celle qui
nous montre le ciel la nuit.
Quand on voit une image comme ça,
tout le monde a vu une image comme ça.
Déjà, on remarque qu'il
y a une sorte de bande blanche
dans le ciel qui s'appelle la Voie lactée.
Mais lorsqu'on regarde le ciel
la nuit, on en voit jamais
qu'un petit bout de la Voie lactée
pour la voir, pour la voir en entier.
Il faudrait qu'on puisse prendre
des photos de chaque nuit de la Terre
et de les rassembler
ensuite en ayant fait le tour du monde.
Et bien c'est ce qu'a fait
un télescope européen qui s'appelle Gaia,
qui a pris quelques dizaines de milliers
de photographies du ciel la nuit
et qui les a mises
bout à bout. Et ça a donné ça
l'image que vous voyez là, c'est
une vraie photo.
C'est un amalgame de dizaines de milliers
de photos qui ont été mises bout à bout.
En gros, c'est ce que vous verriez là
maintenant si la Terre était transparente,
si les murs étaient transparents,
si on était dehors
et que vous pouviez voir l'univers
en entier partout sans être pollué
par les lumières terrestres,
on verrait quelque chose comme ça.
Alors
on pourrait se dire c'est joli,
mais ça ressemble à quoi ?
Pourquoi est ce que c'est
une barre comme ça qui est autour ?
En regardant tous les petits points
qui sont là, on a réussi à déterminer
leur distance, la distance de toutes
les étoiles qui nous entourent.
Et du coup, on a pu imaginer
à quoi ça ressemble vu du dessus.
Voici une simulation
qui est une vraie carte.
En fait de la Voie lactée.
Vue du dessus,
c'est ce qu'on appelle une galaxie.
C'est notre galaxie et c'est le nom
qu'on lui a donné.
C'est la Voie lactée.
Évidemment, comme nous,
on est l'espèce la plus importante
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
et du cosmos.
On est en plein centre,
Non ?
En réalité, on est en grande banlieue.
Le soleil, il est par là
et on le voit même pas tellement
il est petit et il n'est qu'une étoile
parmi environ deux ou 300 milliards
qui composent notre Voie lactée
que vous voyez là,
On y reviendra tout à l'heure.
Pour l'instant,
on va aller vers l'univers lointain.
On va essayer d'aller
voir plus loin que la Voie lactée.
Alors quand on regarde à l'œil nu
le soleil, il était par là,
à l'œil nu, toutes les étoiles
qu'on voit dans la nuit,
c'est à peu près contenue là dedans,
c'est minus.
On en voit quelques milliers,
quelques dizaines de milliers
quand on a des bons yeux, mais c'est tout
en faisant le tour de la terre
à peu près.
Mais il
existe des petits points dans le ciel,
surtout depuis vu depuis l'hémisphère sud,
qui sont visibles à l'œil nu
et qui ne font pas
partie de la Voie lactée.
Il y en a trois sur cette image.
Il y a ça, ça et ça.
On va commencer par ces deux là.
Si on zoome vers eux en prenant des
photos, on voit, on s'en rapproche un peu.
Ce sont deux nuages de nuages
qui s'appelle Les Nuages de Magellan.
En haut à droite, c'est le Grand Nuage
de Magellan et en bas à gauche, là,
c'est le Petit Nuage de Magellan.
Tous les petits points que vous voyez
là, Partout,
ce sont des étoiles
qui appartiennent à la Voie lactée.
Les deux nuages qui sont
là sont bien loin derrière.
Vous savez, quand vous voulez
communiquer avec quelqu'un sur terre,
aujourd'hui, on utilise le téléphone
portable qui transforme votre voix
en une onde électromagnétique de Maxwell
qui va à la vitesse de la lumière
jusqu'au portable
que vous appelez
avec lequel vous communiquez.
Donc, on peut dire que quand on parle
à quelqu'un avec un portable,
la voix se propage à la vitesse.
La lumière.
Lorsque vous appelez quelqu'un
qui est sur la lune,
votre voix va mettre une seconde
pour aller jusqu'à la lune.
Parce que la lumière met une seconde
pour aller de la Terre à la Lune.
Si vous appelez quelqu'un
qui est dans le Grand Nuage de Magellan,
là, en haut à droite,
la lumière va voyager pendant 160 000 ans
avant d'arriver là bas
d'un peu plus près, il ressemble à ça.
Et si on zoome vers la partie
un peu colorée rosée bleue,
on voit ce genre d'images.
Ça, c'est une image
qui a été prise par Hubble.
Ce sont des vraies couleurs,
vos yeux verts, et ça,
juste à côté de cet endroit,
il y a un autre endroit qui a été pris
par Hubble aussi, qui ressemble à ça.
C'est des nuages de poussière
absolument gigantesques.
Cette lumière, cette photo,
ce n'est pas que de la lumière visible,
il y a aussi un peu d'infrarouge
et un peu d'ultra violet
dans la plupart des images que je vais
vous montrer, toutes celles de Hubble,
quasiment sans lumière visible,
ça correspond à ce que vos yeux voient.
Toutes celles de James Webb, en revanche,
ne sont pas faites dans une lumière
que nos yeux voient.
Elles font partie de ces lumières
qui remplissent le monde et l'univers,
mais que nos yeux ne perçoivent pas.
Donc elles ont été transformées.
Elles ont été traduites dans des couleurs
que nos yeux peuvent comprendre
et peuvent voir. Et sur cette image là,
James Webb, il a zoome sur cette partie
et vous allez voir.
C'est une des premières images
que James Webb nous a offert l'an dernier
alors qu'il venait d'être
envoyé dans l'espace.
Tous les petits points bleus qui sont
au centre, il y en a environ 10 000.
Ce sont des étoiles
qu'on avait jamais vu auparavant.
Ce sont des nouvelles étoiles
qu'on découvre parce les rayons
infrarouges de James Webb
permettent de traverser
la poussière et
les jeunes étoiles
qui existent dans notre univers
émettent énormément de lumière infrarouge
que d'autres télescopes
ne peuvent pas percevoir.
Ça, ça veut dire que même autour de nous,
il y a des petites galaxies qui sont là,
dans lesquelles il se passe des choses.
Là, les galaxies,
les étoiles bleues sont des étoiles
toutes jeunes,
donc des étoiles qui viennent de naître.
Et on sent qu'il
y a une sorte de souffle qui a créé, qui a
qui a sculpté cette cavité à l'intérieur
de la poussière.
À l'intérieur de ce nuage là,
on est ici.
On ne va pas s'appesantir.
On ne va pas rester trop longtemps à côté.
Nous, on va aller regarder ce point là là.
Maintenant, ce point là en grand Eden, ça,
c'est une vraie photo.
À nouveau, c'est une autre galaxie.
On l'appelle Andromède.
Si vous envoyez un signal lumineux
vers Andromède,
si vous voulez parler avec quelqu'un
là bas, votre voix,
cette fois ci, va devoir voyager
pendant plus de 2 millions d'années.
On dit que Andromède est à 2 millions
d'années lumière de nous.
Ça, ça veut dire qu'il existe d'autres
galaxies autour de nous dans l'espace.
Alors
on a parfois peut être un peu de mal
à se repérer sur les choses
qu'on voit dans l'espace.
Du coup, je vous ai mis
des petits graphiques là, en bas à droite,
c'est la Voie lactée qui est là
et tous les petits points qui sont autour.
Ce sont des galaxies naines, des galaxies
qui sont des satellites de notre galaxie
à nous qui lui tournent,
qui sont en orbite
autour de notre galaxie,
tout comme les planètes
sont en orbite autour du Soleil.
Là vous avez Andromède pour aller de là.
Là, il y a 2000000 d'années
à la vitesse de la lumière.
Tout ce que vous voyez là,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le groupe local.
Quand on est sur terre, on appartient tous
et toutes à des groupes.
Vous avez votre maison,
votre palier, votre quartier,
votre ville, votre pays, votre région,
votre pays, votre continent et la terre.
On peut créer une hiérarchie
d'appartenance
sur terre.
Dans l'espace, c'est pareil,
il y a le système solaire,
c'est le soleil et les planètes
qui lui tournent autour avec les cailloux.
En gros, dans l'espace
qui crée une famille, c'est
lorsque des objets sont reliés
par propre gravité.
C'est parce que les courbes dans l'espace
et le temps font que les objets restent
proches les uns des autres.
Si vous allez aller trop loin,
les objets vont être attirés
par un autre astre, plus loin.
Donc ça va être une autre famille
autour du soleil.
La famille du Soleil,
c'est le système solaire.
Ce sont les planètes, les astéroïdes,
les comètes qui sont autour de nous.
Au niveau des galaxies, c'est pareil.
On appartient à un groupe de galaxies
qui contient environ 45 ans de galaxies
qu'on appelle le groupe local et que voici
et la petite galaxie qui est en bas.
Là, un Wolf qu'on appelle WLM
avec les initiales de Wolf,
une marque Melotte qui les ont.
Ce sont les trois personnes
qui l'ont découvert.
Cette galaxie est
à la limite du groupe local.
Si on va un tout petit peu plus loin
et bien va être attiré par autre chose.
La voie WLM
elle est à 3 millions d'années
lumière de nous.
Pour vous montrer à quel point
les technologies nous permettent
d'avoir des visions un peu différente
en zoomant à
l'intérieur de WLM, le télescope
le plus puissant en infrarouge avant
James Webb avait vu ça
exactement
le même endroit,
la même image vu par James Webb,
ça donne ça,
c'est mieux.
Vous vouliez faire Wow !
On voit deux choses dans cette image.
Déjà,
on voit que plein d'étoiles apparaissent.
Tous les petits points qui sont là,
ce sont des étoiles de WLM.
On voit aussi au travers
qu'il existe d'autres galaxies.
Il y en a une en haut à gauche, là,
un peu spirale qui est jolie.
Mais ce qui signifie
que notre groupe local
pas la fin de notre univers WLM
que vous voyez.
Donc vous voyez là un petit bout lié,
y a d'autres choses beaucoup plus loin.
Eh bien on est allé voir.
Hubble
déjà était allé voir s'il
y avait d'autres choses plus loin.
On les connaissait
même avec d'autres télescopes.
Celle là, elle est donc à 3 millions
d'années lumière de nous.
Et celle qui apparaît maintenant, elle est
à 29 millions d'années lumière de nous.
Elle appartient,
elle est au delà du groupe local.
Elle fait partie d'un son autre,
dans un autre petit groupe dans l'espace.
Ça, c'est de la lumière visible.
C'est Abel,
C'est comme ça que vous la verriez
avec des grands yeux
si vous aviez du temps
et que vous étiez dans l'espace.
Et on a demandé à James Webb
de prendre exactement cette image en photo
et ça a donné ça.
Vous imaginez ce que vous faites là
en rigolant ?
Vous imaginez les scientifiques
qui arrivent le matin devant la valeur
d'un ordinateur grâce au programmateur,
qui ont transformé les données en images
et qui voient ça ?
Ils ne disent pas quoi ils font ?
Oh, mais ce n'est pas possible,
C'est dingue.
Je vous en montre une autre,
celle là.
Les 3 millions d'années
lumière de plus loin encore,
elle est à 32 millions d'années lumière
et on va zoomer sur son centre.
Vous êtes près ?
Il y a deux choses qui sont amusantes
sur cette image.
La première, c'est au centre.
On voit bien qu'il
y a plein d'étoiles nouvelles qui sont là.
Les petites étoiles qui brillent en bleu,
il y en a plein.
Des dizaines de milliers partout ailleurs.
On voit qu'il y a des endroits
qui sont plus chargés que d'autres,
comme là, là, un peu partout.
Ce sont des endroits où des étoiles
sont en train de naître.
Des pouponnières d'étoiles,
vous ai dit Les étoiles naissantes jeunes
émettent énormément de rayons
ultra infrarouges
qui peuvent à leur tour
faire avoir un impact sur les nuages
à l'intérieur
desquels ces étoiles se sont formées,
qui font rayonner ces nuages.
Donc ça crée des endroits de lumière
qui n'apparaissait pas exactement comme ça
en lumière visible.
Mais il y a un autre truc qui est marrant
est ce que je vous laisse dix secondes
pour les discuter avec votre voisin
pour essayer de voir
ce qui est étrange dans cette photo ?
19 de
la spirale est en train de se développer
pas mal,
pas mal.
Moi je vous le dis parce que là,
il y a un trou
sûr qui est tellement évident
qu'on le voit pas.
Mais il y a un vrai trou et personne
ne comprend d'où il vient ce trou.
Il y a probablement quelque soit
une explosion, mais les distances
sont tellement colossales
que c'est dur à imaginer.
Soit il y a peut être un objet
ou une autre galaxie
qui est venue transpercer cette galaxie
là, laissant un derrière.
Je n'ai pas la réponse.
Donc si quelqu'un parmi vous, c'est
pourquoi ce trou est là, n'hésitez
pas à le dire,
on est encore plus loin.
250 millions d'années lumière de nous.
Et là, maintenant,
on va faire un petit bond conceptuel.
Je vous propose de faire un petit voyage
là, montre à chaque fois
cette petite vidéo.
C'est une vidéo qui a été faite
par les équipes du Sloan
Digital avec SDS.
C'est un groupe de chercheurs
qui crée une sorte de cartographie
de l'univers qui est autour de nous
grâce aux données
qui sont récoltées par les télescopes.
Est ce que vous allez voir maintenant ?
C'est
pour vous donner une petite idée en détail
des choses qui sont autour de nous.
C'est film des 400 000 galaxies
qui entourent la nôtre dans l'espace
et je vous propose
qu'on regarde ça dans le noir.
Là, chacun des points que vous voyez,
c'est
une galaxie qui contient
environ 300, 200, 300
milliards de soleils.
Et on estime qu'il y a environ
deux ou trois planètes par étoiles.
Normalement, ça rend humble.
Pas toujours, mais normalement.
Alors
là, vu qu'on reste dans le noir
quelques instants, vous pouvez répondre
en toute franchise et en toute honnêteté,
personne ne vous voit,
vous levez la main
quand vous croyez que ça correspond
en voyant ce genre de choses
qui va rester en noir d'ozone ?
Qui parmi vous dans la salle pense
qu'il existe des extraterrestres ?
Quelque dans l'univers ?
J'aime bien quand on pose cette question
dans le noir parce que
c'est un peu flippant, ce qui pense qu'on
est seul dans l'univers. OK.
Et qui pense
qu'il existe des extraterrestres là ?
Maintenant, dans la salle.
Est ce qu'on continue dans le noir
parce que ceux qui n'ont pas levé la main,
ni à la première, ni
à la deuxième question en général,
ce sont eux les extraterrestres.
On peut rallumer.
Nous sommes dans la Voie lactée.
Andromède, WLM
que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure.
Notre groupe local
d'une quarantaine de galaxies s'est donc
perdu à l'intérieur de ces 400 millions.
Cette petite famille
à laquelle on appartient,
qui est là dedans.
Il y a quelques années,
en faisant ces cartographies,
il y a un groupe d'astronomes
qui a réalisé que notre petit groupe local
fait partie, avec d'autres petits groupes,
d'un groupe plus grand
que voici qu'on appelle l'année
Aquila qui contient environ 100 galaxies.
A chaque fois, les petits points
sont des galaxies et tout le groupe local.
Et qu'on s'est contenu dans le petit truc
bleu qui est là Et le groupe d'astronomes
qui ont découvert cette structure
là contient une astronome française
qui s'appelle, Hélène Courtois,
qui a écrit plein de livres
que je vous conseille de lire.
Ils sont très bien et qui nous a découvert
qu'on nous a appris que nous appartenons
à cette structure gigantesque
qu'on appelle l'ENIAC.
Et toute cette structure là,
on sait aujourd'hui,
appartient à un univers plus grand encore.
C'est
juste le point du centre là d'Adiaké.
Dans cette ensemble d'autres
super structures de galaxies.
Et si vous prenez toutes ces structures
qui sont là, c'est juste le petit point
qui est au centre ici, là.
Là, chaque point n'est plus constitué
d'une galaxie,
mais de centaines de milliers de galaxies,
voire de millions d'entre elles
qui créent des formes et qui interagissent
un peu au loin les unes avec les autres.
Ça, c'est une simulation.
On n'a pas détecté tous ces points là.
Là, je vais vous montrer
un petit film à nouveau,
mais qu'on ne peut pas le regarder
comme ça, C'est une animation
dès deux ou 3 millions de galaxies,
les plus proches de nous,
qui ont été détectées.
C'est comme tout à l'heure SDSL,
le Digital Sky SAT,
avec qui il nous a donné ça
chaque petit point.
Là, c'est une galaxie détectée.
Ça date d'il y a quelques années, elle n'a
pas encore été mis à jour cette carte.
Donc on en connaît plus encore.
Mais elle donne une bonne idée
approximative
de ce que nous savons dans notre univers.
Alors je vais répondre à quelques
questions que vous vous posez peut être.
Et si
jamais vous voulez n'est pas,
vous devriez.
La première, c'est pourquoi est ce qu'il
y a des endroits
où on voit rien là
et on ne voit pas tout ça là.
Il n'y a pas de galaxie
dans cette direction là.
Non, c'est pas ça.
Vous souvenez que notre galaxie à nous,
c'est une spirale ?
On l'a vu tout à l'heure du dessus.
Nous, on est dans cette spirale.
Donc pour regarder au travers,
c'est compliqué
parce qu'il y a toutes les étoiles,
tous les nuages de poussière
qui sont partout
pour voir les galaxies lointaines,
surtout les très lointaines,
assez faibles en luminosité.
Il faut qu'on regarde par dessus
ou par dessous, à la verticale,
à la perpendiculaire
de notre galaxie, à nous.
Ce qui veut dire
que là, notre galaxie est comme ça,
orienté, incliné, comme ça.
Et là,
on va au dessus et là, on voit en dessous.
C'est pour ça qu'on ne voit pas ce qu'il
y a sur les côtés.
Ça, c'est la première question.
Vous la pesez.
Et du coup, la deuxième, c'est quoi ?
Bien oui.
Un pour que c'est rond et deux
pourquoi on voit rien ?
C'est quand même dommage.
On a des bons télescopes,
on les pointe vers l'espace.
Pourquoi est ce qu'on voit rien là ?
Alors
la réponse est assez marrante
et elle a à voir
avec tout ce qu'on a vu en théorie
au début de la conférence.
Je vous avais demandé
d'avoir une bonne mémoire.
J'espère que c'est le cas.
Vous souvenez que vous avez dit que
notre univers était fait d'espace temps ?
Oui, très bien.
Vous souvenez que cet espace temps,
il peut être déformé ?
Bon, mais ça veut dire que notre univers
peut avoir
une histoire qui peut changer, et cetera
Et bien, au début du XXᵉ siècle,
lorsque les astronomes ont pointé
les télescopes de l'époque
vers les galaxies lointaines,
ils ont vu une chose ils ont vu que toutes
les galaxies lointaines
s'éloignent de nous, pis
que plus ils sont loin,
plus elle s'éloigne vite.
Alors, ils ont vu ça.
Comment on détecte la vitesse
d'une galaxie,
d'un truc lointain, juste sur une photo ?
Et bien on peut le faire
grâce à la lumière.
Vous savez, quand vous êtes dans la rue
et qu'une voiture passe à côté de vous,
ça fait.
Quand vous serez électrique,
je ne pourrais plus utiliser cet exemple.
Mais pour l'instant, on peut.
Ça fait comme ça.
Ça ne veut pas dire
que la voiture change de son elle même.
C'est qu'il
se trouve que le son est une onde qui,
lorsque la source avance,
va comprimer l'onde qui va avoir des
émettre des vagues plus ratatiné,
plus aigu.
Et lorsque la source s'éloigne,
les ondes vont être étirées derrière.
Ça va être plus grave.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet Doppler.
C'est ça
la vitesse d'un objet qui change le son.
Cet effet,
il existe pour la lumière Aussi,
si un objet va avancer extrêmement vite
et émettre de la lumière,
la lumière ne va pas partir plus vite
parce qu'elle a toujours la même vitesse,
mais elle va être ratatiné.
Et ça, comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure,
quelque chose
qui est ratatiné, c'est plus bleu,
alors que si l'objet s'éloigne
et la lumière va être étirée,
ça va être plus rouge.
Ce qu'on appelle le décalage
vers le rouge.
Lorsqu'un objet plus rouge
qu'il ne l'est en réalité,
sa lumière est décalée vers le rouge.
Alors,
ce qu'ont vu les astronomes
au début du XXᵉ siècle,
c'est que toutes les galaxies lointaines
étaient décalées
vers le rouge.
Je vous laisse réfléchir
à ce que ça signifie.
C'est bon, ça veut dire
qu'on est au centre de l'univers.
Eh bien oui, tout monde s'éloigne de nous.
Forcément, on est au centre de l'univers.
Le temps de boire un verre.
Je vous laisse réfléchir
à une solution à ce problème.
Vous me dites quand ça ?
Eh bien, figurez vous
que la solution est venue
de l'idée suivante
Les scientifiques se sont dit En réalité,
aucune de ces galaxies lointaines
ne bouge et bouge pas du tout.
Elles sont là où elles sont
et c'est comme ça.
Ce qui bouge, en revanche, ce qui change,
c'est la distance
qui nous sépare de ces galaxies.
C'est plus un effet Doppler
qui est lié au mouvement
d'une source lumineuse.
C'est l'espace et le temps lui même.
C'est l'espace temps qui nous sépare de
ces galaxies qui s'étirent dans le temps.
Ça, avec Newton, ce n'était pas possible.
Mais avec Einstein,
avec ce tissu qui remplit tout, ça l'est.
Et tout d'un coup,
quand on prend cette idée, on peut avoir
une onde de lumière
qui va se balader dans l'espace
qui s'étire, l'espace qui s'étire
et qui va étirer du coup l'onde de lumière
en même temps.
Du coup, la lumière va changer de couleur
et va être décalée vers le rouge.
Ça, ça résout
le problème du centre de l'univers.
Parce que si ce sont
les distances qui s'étirent,
alors les objets, certes, s'éloignent tous
de les galaxies lointaines,
mais elles s'éloignent toutes les unes
des autres aussi.
Si là, au centre de la salle,
quelqu'un voyait tout le monde
s'éloignait en courant de vous,
vous poseriez des questions.
Je comprends.
Mais si, au lieu de dire ça,
je dis que ce sont les chiens,
les chaises,
les sièges sur lesquels vous êtes assis
qui vont s'éloigner, vous vous bougez pas.
Si tous les chaises,
toutes les chaises s'éloignent,
eh bien,
toutes les chaises s'éloigneront
de tout le monde
et tout le monde aura l'impression
que tout le monde s'éloigne de vous.
Il n'y aura plus de centre,
vous serez tous les centres d'un univers
qui s'agrandit, d'une
salle qui s'agrandit.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle l'expansion de l'univers.
L'expansion de l'univers, c'est
un univers qui s'agrandit.
Non pas les bords qui s'éloignent,
mais toutes les distances
s'étirent.
Vous allez me dire
quel rapport avec ce truc ?
Il y en a pas.
Si il y en a
le rapport, il est le suivant
si vous avez une étoile extrêmement
lointaine
qui va émettre une certaine lumière,
cette lumière
nous a appris que c'est une onde
qui avance.
Disons que l'étoile, c'est comme le soleil
et disons qu'elle est jaune.
D'accord,
elle va émettre sa lumière jaune,
mais mettre sa lumière jaune,
l'espace
va s'étirer sur son passage de jaune.
Elle va devenir un peu rouge,
beaucoup rouge, très rouge
et puis éventuellement dépasser le rouge
Au moment où elle dépasse le rouge,
elle n'est plus visible,
On ne la voit plus,
elle est rentrée dans l'infrarouge.
Ce qui veut dire que notre univers
ayant une histoire,
notre univers s'étirant
les étoiles les plus lointaines,
on ne devrait plus les voir
en lumière visible dans l'espace
et on les voit plus.
Une des raisons
pour lesquelles on a construit
le télescope Hubble,
c'était pour voir le plus loin
possible dans l'espace et l'image
que je vais vous montrer maintenant, c'est
un champ profond de Hubble.
Qui est qui a essayé d'aller voir delà
de tout ce qu'on voit,
qui a fixé
ce petit point noir entre les étoiles
et qui allait récolter cette lumière
pendant des jours et des jours
et des jours
pour nous donner cette image ?
Cette image
est extrêmement émouvante
parce qu'il y a dessus
la limite de ce qu'on pourra voir
en utilisant la lumière visible.
Il y a la limite de ce qu'on peut voir
avec nos yeux dans notre univers.
Peut être qu'on aura des télescopes
et on en a un.
Je vais vous en parler dans deux secondes
qui va voir plus loin,
mais ce ne sera jamais
avec de la lumière visible.
C'est avec une autre lumière,
c'est avec une lumière infrarouge.
Là, c'est le champ profond de
le champ ultra profonde Hubble,
qui date d'il y a quelques années
et qui nous montre
la limite de notre univers.
Il y a quelques années,
il y a un scientifique américain
qui s'appelle John Mather,
qui a eu le prix Nobel en 1984 pour
nous avoir permis de comprendre
comment lire les effets du Big bang
dans le ciel, dans le ciel de la nuit.
John Matter nous a dit
Il s'est dit lui même Déjà que si on veut
avoir une chance quelconque
d'observer l'enfance
de notre univers lointain,
et bien on est obligé
de construire un télescope qui ne va pas
regarder en lumière, mais qui va regarder
comme balle en infrarouge.
Plus loin encore,
qui va capter cette lumière d'étoiles
qui étaient visibles
et qui ne le sont plus ?
C'est ce qu'on a depuis l'an dernier.
Ce matin,
il a construit James Webb pour ça
et sur cette image là,
il est allé un peu vite
sur cette image là,
chaque carré, une fois de plus,
comme tout à l'heure, c'est
une tête d'épingles tenu à bout de bras,
dans lequel James Webb assumait
sur l'image.
Juste avant que je vais vous rencontrer
dans quelques instants,
il y avait plus de 100 000 galaxies,
ce ne sont que des images
en lumière infrarouge,
donc on voit au delà de Hubble.
Cela dit, certaines des étoiles
et des galaxies que Bâle voyait
émettaient aussi de la lumière
émet de la lumière visible
et de la lumière infrarouge,
ce qui fait que certaines des galaxies
qui sont là, Hubble les voyait déjà.
Mais il y en a d'autres qui sont apparues,
qui n'étaient sur aucun cliché de Hubble
parce que leur lumière n'est pas visible
par Hubble.
Il y en a une sur cette image
en particulier,
dont la lumière nous parvient
après avoir voyagé dans l'espace
pendant presque 13 milliards d'années.
Je vous laisse la trouver.
En gros,
ça ressemble à un petit point rouge.
La façon dont les scientifiques
trouvent cherche
ce genre de galaxies, c'est qu'ils
regardent leurs clichés Avec James Webb.
Ils regardent leurs clichés avec Hubble,
ils comparent les deux
et ils regardent les endroits où il y a
des nouvelles galaxies qui sont apparues.
C'est des galaxies infrarouges
qui sont beaucoup, beaucoup plus loin.
Après, il y a d'autres techniques
pour aller en voir d'autres,
mais là, il y en a au moins une.
Alors je vous propose de parier
sur celle que vous voulez.
Vous faites votre pari avec votre Voisin,
votre voisine,
et je vous donne la réponse
sur celle là.
Elle est là
et vous l'aviez toutes et tous,
évidemment.
Et en zoomant, ça donne ça.
L'image donne ça
et ce qui est amusant,
elle a 13,2 milliards d'années.
Ce qui est amusant, c'est qu'il
y a trois points là et c'est trois points.
C'est la même image du centre
dans lequel il y a un
il y a un gros trou noir.
Si on revient sur l'image globale
où il y a à peu près
100 zéro zéro galaxies qui sont là,
je vous donne une deuxième chance.
Il y en a deux autres qui sont à environ
treize d'années lumière.
En 20 ans,
on en a trouvé une bonne quinzaine
déjà sur ces images là
et on continue à en trouver.
Ce qui est amusant, c'est
qu'elles datent de cet été.
Ces images et ce qui veut dire qu'il
y a de fortes chances
que consciemment ou non,
en les regardant là maintenant,
vous êtes en train de voir des galaxies
qu'aucun n'a vu avant vous.
Il y a 100 galaxies qui sont là,
qui étaient complètement.
La plupart, pour la plupart inconnues,
n'en ont pas toutes certaines.
Mais il y a ces petits points
que les scientifiques
cherchent encore aujourd'hui.
Ils les ont pas toutes trouvées.
Il analyse ces images là
pendant que nous on discute.
Ils sont en train de bosser à faire ça
et donc il y en a au moins
deux autres que je vais vous montrer.
C'est bon, vous les avez.
Il y en a une qui est là
à 12,7 milliards d'années lumière de nous
et celle là qui est à 12,8
milliards d'années.
Le télescope James Webb,
qui voit en infrarouge, permet de voir
à travers la poussière
ultra loin des galaxies
qui existaient
durant l'enfance de notre univers.
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
l'espace pouvait déformer
les images des galaxies lointaines.
Lorsqu'il y a une galaxie entre nous
et elles,
ça fait des sortes de lentilles
gravitationnelles.
Ça faisait l'hameçon
qu'on avait vu Orange au départ,
mais en réalité,
ça ne fait pas que déformer.
Est ce que ça fait aussi ?
C'est que c'est magnifique ça fait comme
une loupe
grâce aux lentilles gravitationnelles.
Grâce au fait que la lumière puisse
prendre plusieurs chemins
pour arriver jusqu'à nous,
on a des images bien
plus puissantes
que celles qu'on aurait censées lentille.
On peut voir beaucoup plus loin
grâce à ces zoom naturel
et cette image
là qui est un des premiers champs
profonds de Hubble
qui a été publiée en février dernier.
Elle continue
à être analysée et en novembre,
le 13 novembre, il y a la deuxième galaxie
la plus éloignée qu'on ait jamais vue,
qui a été trouvée sur ce cliché.
Elle est là
le petit point rouge qui est là
et qui est en photo.
Et là, on parle d'une galaxie qui a existé
300 millions d'années après le big Bang.
Alors
est ce que ce sont des découvertes sympa ?
Oui, en soi, c'est rigolo.
Et est ce que ça correspond
exactement à ce qu'on
s'imaginait être notre univers ?
Et bien c'est là que c'est amusant.
Parce que non, il y a des mystères
qui apparaissent avec ces galaxies là.
Par exemple, on réalise.
On sait qu'aujourd'hui
toutes les galaxies que vous avez vu,
les 400 000,
ensuite les plus en plus gros.
Il existe dans leur cœur un trou noir
supermassif qui peut faire jusqu'à
entre un et 60 milliards
de soleil, de masses solaires.
Il y a un trou noir supermassif
au centre de notre galaxie.
On l'appelle Sagittarius A étoile.
Lui, il est minus.
Il fait 4 millions
de fois la masse du Soleil.
Et mais je vous dis, les plus gros
qu'on connaisse font jusqu'à
60 milliards de fois la masse du soleil.
Mais là,
on regarde ces galaxies anciennes.
Qu'est ce qu'on essaie de faire ?
On essaie de voir l'enfance
de toutes les galaxies, de notre univers.
On essaye de voir
comment elles se sont développées,
elles ont existé,
quelle est leur histoire ?
Comment, au fond, est arrivé
notre galaxie à nous,
en regardant l'évolution
des autres galaxies qui nous entourent,
on peut répondre à la question de savoir
quelle est l'histoire de la Voie lactée,
de notre Voie lactée, de notre galaxie,
comment elle est née,
comment elle est apparue,
comment son trou noir est venu,
comment sont apparus
les trous noirs des autres galaxies ?
Eh bien, ces derniers mois,
alors qu'on avait une sorte d'image
plus ou moins cohérente
de ce qui s'était passé,
on a réalisé que les trous noirs
au centre des galaxies primordiales,
dont celle là, sont beaucoup trop gros
par rapport à leur galaxie.
On ne comprend pas comment ils ont fait
pour devenir si gros,
si vite par rapport à leur galaxie.
En fait, quand vous avez une galaxie
avec des milliards, un trou noir
qui fait des milliards de fois
la masse du soleil en son centre,
comment est ce qu'il est arrivé là ?
Est ce que c'est la galaxie
qu'il a nourrie et il est devenu gros ?
Est ce qu'il était là avant la galaxie ?
Et les étoiles
sont venues se mettre autour.
C'est ce qu'on
essaye de déterminer
en voyant les galaxies lointaines.
Mais c'est pire encore.
Parce que sur cette autre image
de James Webb qui apparaît ici
et qui est assez marrante, où il y a
encore énormément de galaxies partout,
il y a un point
qui intrigue énormément les scientifiques.
Alors là, vous avez du bol
parce qu'il est en plein milieu.
C'est lui
les télescopes,
parfois crédit et vous voyez,
il y a des traits là.
Ça en général,
c'est lorsque la est beaucoup trop forte,
comme avec un téléphone
ou quoi que ce soit.
Un appareil photo avec.
Vous voulez prendre une photo la nuit ?
S'il y a un lampadaire,
vous allez avoir des trains cd.
C'est des déformations
qui sont liées au télescope lui même.
Ça s'appelle des figures de diffraction
lorsqu'elles ont huit branches
comme un peu partout ici,
ce sont des diffraction de James Webb.
Vous savez que c'est déjà ça.
C'est un truc là pour frimer.
Si vous marchez dans la rue
un jour avec un ami ou une amie,
vous marchez tranquillement.
Et puis il y a une image d'étoiles
et parfois il y en a
et vous voyez huit branches comme ça.
Vite, il faut compter.
Et vous regardez, vous faites, c'est web,
vous pouvez faire comme ça,
juste en passant.
Et parce que les autres télescope Hubble,
ce n'est pas à huit,
ça peut être quatre, parfois six,
mais pas huit huit.
C'est Webb.
Si on vous demande pourquoi vous dites ça,
tu ne vas pas comprendre.
T'inquiète,
cette image là.
Là, on parle
d'étoiles qui ne sont pas très loin,
qui sont dans notre galaxie à nous.
Mais celle là, elle est beaucoup,
beaucoup beaucoup plus loin.
En fait,
elle est à plusieurs dizaines à plusieurs,
elle est à plus de 10 milliards d'années
lumière de nous.
C'est la lumière émise
par un trou noir au centre d'une galaxie,
alors qu'il est en train de dévorer
des étoiles qui lui tombent dedans.
C'est un trou noir absolument gigantesque
qui fait à peu près 12 milliards de fois
la masse du soleil.
Et là, on le voit tel qu'il était
il y a un peu plus de 12 milliards
et demi d'années
et on sait
notre univers a environ 13,8 milliards
d'années d'existence
et on ne comprend pas comment,
en 1 milliard d'années,
un trou noir a pu devenir aussi gros.
C'est juste incompréhensible.
C'est comme s'il avait mangé un soleil
par mois pendant 1 milliard d'années.
Ça fait beaucoup.
On comprend pas, ça a pu arriver.
Ça fait partie des mystères
que ces télescopes là vont peut être nous
permettre de lever un de ces quatre
là. On est aller loin dans l'univers.
Maintenant, je vous ai dit que
de regarder autour de nous
nous permet
de comprendre le passé de notre galaxie.
Et on a réalisé
que notre propre galaxie,
en voyant la façon dont elle tourne,
les étoiles qui sont en elle,
la composition des choses à.
Différents endroits.
La Voie lactée est le résultat
d'une collision.
En gros, la gueule, allez vous le dis tout
net, la galaxie a bouffé une dizaine
d'autres galaxies
avant devenir ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui.
Donc il y a eu des collisions.
Notre galaxie est devenue
de plus en plus grande en mangeant
les petites galaxies satellites
qui sont autour d'elles.
Alors vous allez me dire très bien
et en quoi est ce que ça nous concerne ?
Et bien ça nous concerne
peut être par rapport à son futur.
Du coup, je vous propose de jeter un coup
d'œil maintenant
au futur de la Voie lactée.
Alors la Voie lactée, je vous le rappelle,
c'est ça hein ?
C'est notre galaxie à nous. Nous, on est.
On a été par la loi,
on s'en va, mais on n'est pas là
et on la voit comme ça.
Vous souvenez qu'il
y avait le grand Nuage de Magellan,
le Petit Nuage de Magellan
et la galaxie Andromède
Andromède, Quand on la regarde
en photos dans le ciel la nuit.
Aujourd'hui, elle ressemble à ça.
C'est ce petit point là.
Sauf que
on l'a analysé,
on l'a regardé,
on s'est dit Tiens, elle bouge à bouche.
Elle va dans quelle direction ?
Et cetera Elle vient vers nous ?
Oh d'accord.
Donc elle se rapproche de nous.
OK, pas de problème, vite, assez vite.
Est ce qu'elle va nous rentrer dedans ?
Oui, ça va nous rentrer dedans.
Et là, je vais vous montrer
à quoi va ressembler le ciel
dans les années à venir.
Au fur
et à mesure, Andromède se rapproche et
nous rentre dedans.
Accrochez vous, ça c'est aujourd'hui vrai.
Photos
maintenant on pendant la simulation.
Vous voulez que je vous dise tout de suite
dans combien de temps ça non ?
Hop là,
là, on est dans 3,7 milliards
d'années, ça va, on est tranquille
et à chaque fois,
maintenant qu'on va augmenter le temps,
on va rajouter entre 50 et 100 millions
d'années.
Hop, alors là,
ils vont être bien trippé.
J'adore l'idée de dire
on va se balader la nuit
et ils vont voir ça.
Ils vont avoir des mythes et
des mythologies, des histoires
à se raconter qui vont être assez folles.
Il y a quelques instants
où elles vont être séparées
parce qu'elles vont se tourner autour
l'une de l'autre, se rentrer dedans.
Il y a des moments
où elles vont redevenir séparées ici
pour, au final,
ne faire plus qu'une galaxie
comme celle là.
Ça, c'est le ciel. Au final,
on passe par une étape assez jolie
et après ça redevient un peu ennuyeux.
Et qu'est ce qui est ce que c'est
dangereux ?
La collision de deux galaxies
comme ça, en vrai ?
Pas tant que ça.
Parce qu'au temps de loin,
on a l'impression que ce sont des disques
qui sont bien solides, bien costauds.
Autant elles sont faites d'étoiles
qui sont tellement
les unes des autres que deux galaxies
qui se rentre dedans, c'est comme deux gaz
qui vont se tourner autour,
comme deux vols de passereaux
qui vont se rentrer dedans.
Mais il n'y en a pas
un seul qui se touchent en vrai
et c'est pas exclu qu'il y ait des étoiles
qui se rentre dedans, mais ce n'est pas
la norme.
C'est vraiment des endroits où ça va,
ça va passer, ça va être
très joli les collisions,
les réelles collisions dans les dents.
Lorsque les galaxies se rentre dedans,
ce sont les poussières, c'est
les nuages de poussière.
Eux, ils vont se rentrer dedans,
créer des zones denses
et c'est dans ces zones plus denses
que de nouvelles étoiles vont naître.
Donc en gros, les collisions de galaxies,
ça fait naître
plus d'étoiles que ça n'en détruit.
Comme on sait que c'est
possible ces collisions de galaxies,
eh bien, on envoie dans l'espace.
En voici une.
Là, il y a une galaxie.
Ici, on voit le bras qui est un petit peu
arraché par l'approche de l'autre.
Et vous voyez sur la galaxie du haut
qu'il y a de ces six endroits un peu rose
qui font face à la galaxie, qui approchent
en bas ces un endroit un peu rose.
Ce sont ces endroits où les poussières
sont attirées par l'autre
et se rendent dedans et donnent naissance
à de nouvelles étoiles.
Il y en a un et
là, c'est une image en lumière visible.
C'est une image que nos yeux peuvent voir.
Et si on utilise James Webb
pour regarder cette image
et on peut peut être voir
des choses nouvelles à nouveau.
Par exemple, on peut voir s'il existe
au cœur de ces galaxies
des trous noirs actifs
qui sont en train de manger leurs étoiles.
Et dans celle du haut, il y a une lumière
qui est tellement puissante,
qui nous apparaît qu'on sait qu'il
y a un trou noir gigantesque qui existe.
On va venir dans quelques instants, mais
je donne un autre exemple de collision.
Ça, c'est le coin tête de
le quintette de Stéphane
du nom d'un astronome français
qui les a découvert.
Il y en a cinq, il y en a une en bas,
il y en a deux au milieu
qui sont un peu orange,
une au milieu à gauche,
qui est bleue et une autre en haut,
celle qui est bleue.
Elle est à une quarantaine de millions
d'années lumière de nous
et elle est assez proche de nous.
Les quatre autres sont bien plus loin,
à environ 340 millions
d'années lumière de nous,
et elles sont vraiment beaucoup plus loin.
C'est pour ça que leur couleur
est différente, avec le décalage
vers le rouge, et cetera Mais on voit
que celles du milieu déjà rentre dedans.
Les deux orange du milieu,
on voit des sortes de filets,
on devine des filets un petit peu partout.
En réalité, les quatre orange
sont en train de se rentrer dedans.
On peut regarder avec James Webb.
Ça, c'était à Bâle et James Webb
en regardant le même endroit.
Il a vu ça.
Merci.
Et en changeant
de couleur.
Même en infrarouge,
il y a des couleurs différentes.
Il a vu ça
et là on
voit les endroits où des étoiles
sont en train de naître.
Et si on se rapproche,
on voit les endroits de poussière
qui sont éjectés, Qui ?
Ce qui rentre en collision.
Partout où il y a la poussière
qui est un peu courbée dans les endroits
où, en tournoyant,
ça crée des gerbes de poussière.
Mais si vous regardez l'image du haut,
vous voyez qui est deux traits
en là et en là, qui sont plutôt verticaux,
qui sont plutôt à la perpendiculaire
de la galaxie qui est là.
Et bien ces gens là,
ils ne sont pas dûs à la collision.
Ils sont une fois de plus liés
à l'existence d'un trou noir
absolument colossal
qui est au centre de la galaxie.
En fait,
il y en a dans les galaxies du bas aussi,
et il apparaît clairement sur cette image
avec une autre
et une autre longueur d'onde.
Pourquoi je vous montre ça ?
Parce que je vous ai dit
que quand deux galaxies se rendent dedans
pour les étoiles, ce n'est pas très grave
parce qu'en général
elles se rendent pas dedans.
Elles se comme de nuages de gaz.
En revanche, pour la poussière,
ça crée des étoiles.
Mais que se passe t il pour les trous
noirs au centre de ces galaxies ?
Il y en a un au centre de la Voie lactée
qui fait 44 millions de fois
la masse du soleil.
Il y en a au centre d'Andromède, qui fait
70 millions de fois la masse du Soleil.
Est ce que c'est possible
qui se rentre dedans ?
Eh bien oui, se rentreront
probablement dedans.
Et on a d'autres exemples
comme cette galaxie là
qui est le résultat final d'une galaxie
de deux galaxies qui sont entrées dedans
et la grosse lumière
avec la figure de diffraction au centre.
C'est ce qui reste.
C'est
une lumière émise par deux trous noirs
gigantesques qui sont
en train de se tourner autour de l'autre
et de se rapprocher et qui vont pas tarder
à se rentrer dedans.
J'adore dire pas tarder
quand on parle d'astronomie
parce que ça veut dire que les astronomes
sont au taquet en train de regarder
leurs télescopes non-stop parce que
là, c'est quelque chose qui va arriver.
Et là, ils vont ils ?
Ils rentrer dans ?
Je disais qu'on dit qu'il faut se dépêcher
comme les trous noirs.
Dans 2 millions d'années à peu près,
ils vont se rentrer dedans.
Ce qui nous amène
à la dernière partie de ce que je voulais
vous raconter aujourd'hui.
On va revenir dans notre galaxie
à nous telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui,
lorsqu'on la regarde dans le ciel,
lorsqu'on se souvient
que le soleil est par ici
et que nous, ce que nos yeux peuvent
percevoir, c'est à peu près ça,
on se dit qu'il y a énormément de choses
encore à découvrir dans notre galaxie,
À nous notamment que notre galaxie n'est
pas une galaxie qui n'est pas active.
Elle active.
Il y a à l'intérieur de cette belle
spirale énormément d'endroits un peu rose
que vous voyez partout où des étoiles
sont en train de naître et à James Webb.
Pour la première fois dans notre histoire,
on peut approcher ces étoiles
qui sont en train de naître.
Alors, si on vise un peu
le centre de notre galaxie
ou un peu partout dans notre galaxie,
on voit ce genre d'images.
On va se remettre dans le noir
pour ce petit voyage
là. Tous les petits points
sont des étoiles de notre galaxie
et on voit qu'il
y a des formes particulières
qui apparaissent par endroits.
Ces formes là,
ce sont des nuages de poussière.
C'est la poussière qu'ont laissé
derrière elle des étoiles qui ont explosé.
Des étoiles comme celles là qui sont vues.
Cela a été vue par Hubble ou celle là,
la même vue par James Webb.
Ça, c'est une photo qui date d'il
y a quelques mois.
Et cette poussière dans l'espace,
elle se propage à chaque fois
et elle inonde notre elle.
Elle ensemence quelque part
notre univers de nouvelle matière.
Et comme le disait ma tête tout à l'heure,
je voulais garder une image
particulière qui est celle ci
d'une étoile qui a explosé.
Et cette image là, elle date de ce matin.
Elle a été publiée ce matin par James Webb
et on voit dessus
la poussière d'une étoile qui
a complètement explosé et qui va alimenter
des nuages de gaz qui sont un peu partout
dans notre galaxie.
Et ces nuages de gaz qui peuvent
des formes
un peu particulières comme celle là,
comme celui là.
Vous avez là
ce qu'on appelle une nébuleuse.
Celle là,
elle s'appelle Les piliers de la création.
La taille est absolument colossale.
Si on se dirige vers un de ces sommets,
on peut se demander d'où
viennent ces formes.
Mais en réalité,
il y a des étoiles qui sont nées au dessus
par là haut
et qui ont irradier le nuage
qui leur a donné naissance.
Ce qui fait que tous ces endroits
là ont été soufflés.
Mais là et là, il y a des endroits
qui sont plus denses, qui ont créé
des boucliers et qui ont protégé
tout ce qui est derrière.
Et on ne sait pas dans ce nuage là.
Mais si on pouvait zoomer à l'intérieur,
ce qu'a fait Hubble à un autre endroit,
on voit qu'à l'intérieur de ces nuages,
il y a des
des choses comme ça.
Ça, c'est ce qu'on voit
à l'intérieur
des nébuleuses dans notre galaxie
et d'endroits intéressants là dedans,
figurez vous.
C'est le petit très noir
qui est au centre du sablier.
Ça, c'est
une sorte d'anneaux de poussière.
C'était une sorte disque
qui s'est effondré sur lui même
et qui a donné naissance en son centre
à une nouvelle étoile.
Si on pouvait aller voir à l'intérieur
de ce petit trait noir, on verrait
ceci.
Alors là, pour le coup, c'est
une simulation.
Ce n'est pas un vrai film.
Là, on a de la poussière d'étoiles
qui a explosé,
qui s'est réunie sous forme d'anneau
et qui s'effondre au centre.
Et là, on est en train d'assister
en animation à la naissance d'une étoile.
Au centre de ce nuage.
Et si vous regardez bien là,
il y a une petite boule qui va apparaître.
C'est une planète.
C'est comme ça que naissent les étoiles
et les planètes dans notre.
On arrive à le voir maintenant.
Et le petit très noir
que vous aviez dans le sablier précédent,
c'est parce qu'on voyait
cet anneau se baignaient de la tranche.
l'Étoile était cachée,
elle a soufflé avec son sa lumière
et c'est radiation toute la matière
qui était au dessus d'elle.
Ce qui fait que ça a créé
des cônes au dessus de cette étoile
dont les parois
sont illuminée par l'étoile elle même.
On en
a plein des images comme dans l'espace.
Là, on voit les jets créés par une étoile
qui est en train de naître.
Là, c'est le beignet.
Il est là, l'étoile,
elle est au centre et elle
éjecte de la poussière en haut et en bas.
On est en entrant en naissant
et on tourne en tournoyant.
Cette image là,
elle date du treize du 14 septembre
et celle ci, qui est une autre étoile
qui est en train de naître à côté de nous,
dans notre galaxie.
Et on voit le petit trait
qui est là encore, le beignet
qu'on voit de la tranche.
C'est là.
Elle date du 28 novembre
et cette image là,
qui est une des qui a été élue
photographie de l'année par James Webb.
Il y a 50
étoiles comme le soleil
sont en train de naître dessus.
Il y en a une qui est par là
et ça, c'est le gigantesque
vers le haut et vers le bas.
Là, il y en a une autre, là,
il y en a encore, Il y en a partout,
partout.
Mais là et là, il y en a
une qui vient de naître et qu'a soufflé
le nuage
et créé cette cavité dans le nuage
qui lui a une fois de plus
donné naissance.
Ce qu'on voit là
sur ces images n'a jamais été vue. Jamais.
Ça fait quelques mois qu'on y a accès.
Jamais. On vu ce genre de choses avant.
Vous savez que dans l'univers,
il y a peut être
d'autres planètes, des scientifiques,
des philosophes, des penseurs.
Depuis des siècles, on imaginait qu'il
pouvait exister des planètes autres
que celles qui tournent autour du Soleil,
des mondes qui existeraient
par milliers dans l'univers.
Mais personne n'avait réussi à le prouver.
Il y en a même qui ont été brûlés vifs,
comme Giordano Bruno par l'Inquisition
en 1600 pour avoir osé émettre l'hypothèse
qu'il existait
des mondes
comme ça à l'infini, dans l'espace,
tous les jours, tous les ans.
En ce moment,
on vérifie non seulement que c'est vrai,
mais on est de plus en plus proche
de voir ces mondes.
On a déjà vu en lumière
directe, visible en photos,
des étoiles autour des planètes,
autour d'autres étoiles.
Mais la première fois qu'on a vu
plusieurs planètes autour de la même
étoile en 2020, et la voici la photo.
Là, on a une étoile qui est cachée
pour ne pas qu'elle ne brille trop.
Il y a une sorte de plaque
devant pour enlever sa lumière.
Là, c'est des étoiles
qui sont loin derrière.
Et ça, ça, ce sont deux planètes
qui tournent autour de cette étoile.
Est ce que James Webb est capable
de faire ce que
d'autres télescopes
commençaient à essayer de réussir ?
Mais il n'arrivait pas vraiment à aboutir
ou à avoir des données précises ?
C'est que de temps en temps, les planètes
vont passer devant leur étoile.
Lorsqu'il y a l'étoile qui est là, nous,
on va regarder une étoile lointaine.
Parfois, la planète va passer devant
et juste sur le côté.
On va avoir.
Si jamais cette planète a une atmosphère,
on va avoir juste un tout
petit bout de l'atmosphère à l'intérieur
duquel va traverser
un rayon de la lumière de son étoile.
Si on arrive à capter ce rayon là
et voir la lumière qui manquerait
par rapport à ce qui est dans l'étoile
elle même, on arrive à déterminer
et la partie de la lumière
qui est captée par l'atmosphère
de la planète lointaine.
Et grâce à ça,
on arrive à déterminer composition
des atmosphères des planètes lointaines.
Je vous donne un exemple.
Ça, c'est la composition
d'une atmosphère prise par James Webb.
On voit qu'il
y a du sodium, de l'eau, du monoxyde
et du dioxyde de carbone,
des dioxyde de soufre.
Des éléments
qu'on commence à connaître ici sur Terre.
Et grâce à ce genre
d'exploration,
peut être que dans les années à venir,
on arrivera à détecter,
grâce à des télescopes comme celui là,
des signes indirects d'une activité
peut être biologique sur les planètes
qui nous entourent dans l'espace.
Donc rester à l'affût.
Si un jour vous voyez un titre de journal
qui nous dit Ah ben tiens,
on a trouvé une autre planète
où il y a peut être
une atmosphère dans laquelle il y a
peut être des êtres vivants
et vous saurez comment on a fait
pour découvrir tout ça aujourd'hui.
Voilà tout ce que je vous ai raconté
jusqu'à présent.
C'est
une petite partie de ce dont est capable
James Webb et d'autres télescopes
qui sont envoyés dans l'espace.
Et j'espère
que vous avez fait un bon voyage avec moi.
Je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté. Je
bon James, Ouais, c'est un copain.
Maintenant on connaît parfaitement.
Merci, Merci Christophe.
Je me demandais
combien de temps de travail
demande la mise en place
d'une conférence
comme celle là pour vous ?
Je ne compte pas.
Je sais, il est vraiment gentil avec nous.
Vraiment, vraiment très généreux.
On va très peu
prendre, prendre très peu de questions
parce que là, vraiment,
on a un petit peu débordé.
Mais ça valait
le coup, Non, c'était tellement mieux.
Voilà.
Alors
je connais Christophe et je pense
qu'il ne voudrait pas que j'en pêche.
Evans, futur astronaute, dix ans,
de poser sa question.
Pas Yvan.
Mais oui,
c'est plus long.
Il est trop ému.
Oscar, est ce que tu as
une question à poser ?
Prends ton temps si tu veux
poser ta question, il réfléchit.
Si c'était Guy qui avait pris la vidéo,
qu'elle
au film là des étoiles.
Spielberg ok.
De quelle vidéo tu parles ?
Non, c'est les étoiles blanches
dans notre Voie lactée.
Alors j'en ai montré plusieurs.
Je ne sais pas si c'est je ne sais pas
à laquelle tu penses, mais si c'est
si c'est si c'est celle là,
Est ce que tu pensais à ça
ou est ce que tu pensais
au galaxie des 400 galaxies
qui étaient tout autour de nous ?
Je crois que oui.
Les galaxies, alors ça,
ce n'est pas une vraie vidéo, c'est
une simulation, C'est à dire
qu'on sait où sont les galaxies.
Toutes celles que tu vois,
on les a détecté.
La plupart, on les a pris en photo
plutôt bien et elles ont été mises
dans une sorte de carte
en trois dimensions à l'intérieur
duquel on a demandé à un ordinateur
de faire une sorte de voyage.
Mais ce n'est pas un voyage
qu'on est capable de faire
en tant qu'humain, vu que le plus loin
qu'on soit aller, c'est la Lune
qui est à une seconde lumière une seconde,
alors que les galaxies
les plus lointaines dans ce qu'on a vu là,
c'est à 1 milliard d'années lumière.
Donc ce n'est pas du tout la même échelle.
C'est vraiment une simulation.
Est ce
que est ce que je peux prendre
la question d'Oscar alors ?
Oscar, onze ans, qui suit
toutes les conférences d'astrophysique ?
Moi, j'ai l'impression.
Alors maman, j'ai perdu la page à lui.
Lui, il écrit ses questions.
Tu l'avais mis où
aller ? Et alors ? On attendant ?
Tu veux que je pose une autre question
en attendant un second jour ?
On va y. Alors
si nous arrivions à entrer
dans un autre univers
et que le tissu soit le même,
mais juste, qu'il y ait un univers de
chaque côté,
cela pourrait il avoir une masse ?
Attendez, je crois que je me suis trompé.
Non, non, c'est bien.
Cela pourrait
il avoir une influence sur notre univers ?
Je ne sais pas si quelqu'un
va répondre est très clair.
Alors
déjà, on
ne sait pas s'il
y a d'autres univers que le nôtre.
D'accord,
on ne sait pas en revanche ce qu'on fait
et qui est assez joli, c'est qu'on arrive
à déterminer les univers possibles
grâce à l'équation d'Einstein
que je vous avais montré au tout début.
C'est où il y avait le signe égal.
Et puis la géométrie
d'un côté et l'énergie de l'autre.
Quand on résout cette équation,
on en trouve des solutions.
Ce qu'on trouve, c'est
un univers possible.
Et ce qui est amusant parfois,
ce qu'on fait certains chercheurs
très forts, c'est qu'à partir
d'une solution,
il de temps en temps
parfois en couper un bout
pour recoller
une autre solution de l'autre côté
et du coup créer un univers plus grand
avec peut être des passages
et des choses
comme ce que t'es en train de décrire.
C'est un peu cette idée, c'est l'idée
qu'on pourrait passer d'un univers
dans notre univers,
soit de cet univers à un autre où comme ça
de relier deux univers. Et
ça peut avoir énormément de conséquences
sur d'autres,
sur certaines choses, par rapport au futur
de ce qui pourrait arriver
ou ou du passé de notre univers.
Ça pourrait avoir plein d'incidence.
Mais dites de manière
complètement générale comme ça,
c'est un peu compliqué pour moi
de donner une réponse très précise.
Alors il y avait,
je voulais dire quand même
1370 spectateurs sur YouTube
qui suivaient cette conférence.
Et monsieur veut poser bonjour
si on lui donne le micro.
Bonsoir, merci pour la conférence.
Si j'ai bien compris
les galaxies très lointaines,
on se rend compte que au cœur
il y a un trou noir qui est trop gros
et est ce que ça veut dire aussi
dans les galaxies sont proches de nous,
les trous noirs devraient être plus
gros qu'ils sont réellement,
alors on arrive à déterminer
la taille de ceux qui sont autour de nous
par leur effet gravitationnel.
On y arrive plus ou moins,
ils on comprend plus.
En fait, en gros,
il faudrait que je refasse une conférence
sur les trous noirs.
Tu pourrais revenir un jour.
En plus
on a trouvé plein de trucs récemment.
C'est marrant, mais
les trous noirs, on va dire qu'il
y a trois possibilités de taille,
disons quatre.
Y a des trous noirs microscopiques
qu'on appelle primordiaux,
que certains suspectent comme Hawking
suspectait.
J'espérais même qu'il a été formé
au début de notre univers.
On les a jamais vus.
Il y a les trous noirs
qu'on comprend le mieux,
tous ceux qui naissent à la mort,
des étoiles gigantesques qui,
lorsqu'elle est pauvre, explosent
leur cœur s'effondre et ça crée
des trous noirs qui font en gros
une dizaine de fois la masse du soleil.
En gros, ensuite, il y a des trous noirs
qui font plusieurs milliers ou jusqu'à
une centaine de milliers de fois
la masse du soleil.
Cela, on ne sait pas trop
comment ils se sont formés,
mais on se doute que c'est plein de
collisions de plus petits.
Et ceux cela, il y en a plein.
On a commencé à les détecter
il y a un an et demi à peu près.
On sait qu'il y en a plein.
On sait que dans notre galaxie à nous,
il y a probablement doute.
Il y a entre 100 et 200 millions de
trous noirs qui traînent un peu partout.
Alors regardez bien
quand vous vous balader
parce qu'on sait jamais où se cache
un trou noir, il y en a pas sur terre,
Il y a des enfants
qui ne nous écoutent pas
et il y a les trous noirs, ensuite,
gigantesques, les supermassifs
qui sont au cœur des galaxies.
Et cela même si on en voit
certains immenses au centre de notre
À l'origine,
dans l'enfance de notre univers,
on ne sait pas,
même s'il était aujourd'hui à dix, 20,
30 milliards d'années et expliquaient
leur évolution jusqu'à cette taille là,
on a gros point d'interrogation
à ce temps là.
Il y a peut être de la matière noire
qui rentre en jeu.
Il y a peut être une autre façon de former
les trous noirs à partir de nuages
de gaz colossaux qui se seraient effondrés
avant même que les galaxies n'existent.
Bref,
il y a plein de solutions potentielles,
mais il y a surtout beaucoup de mystères
encore.
Alors, on prend une dernière question
dans la salle.
Je prendrais ensuite une question Internet
et puis après
je vous laissera aller voir Christophe
Galtier derrière sa table.
Merci beaucoup
pour pour l'ensemble de cette conférence.
Ma question est sur les
dimensions puisque en fait,
on peut maintenant arriver à détecter
des galaxies
à 12,5 12,8 milliards d'années lumière.
En théorie, on peut aller jusqu'à.
On pourrait aller le premier photon
émis à 13 milliards et quelques.
Mais à quelle ?
Quelle est la dimension estimée
de l'ensemble de l'univers ?
Alors
là, il se trouve que
dans la façon dont on voit
l'histoire de notre univers,
je vais vous le faire dans l'autre sens.
On imagine que notre univers est né,
que tout l'univers que nous voyons
est né petit et très chaud,
et qu'il a grandi après.
En imaginant ça, on part du principe
qu'au départ tout était tellement dense
et tellement petit que la lumière n'arrive
même pas à se balader du tout.
Pas que la lumière visible,
mais aucune lumière,
ni X, ni gamma, ni radio,
ni ce que vous voulez.
Rien ne se propageait.
C'était trop dense.
Mais notre univers a grandi
et au bout
d'un moment,
il est devenu transparent à la lumière.
Et ça, c'est la première lumière
qu'on arrive à voir.
Il s'est dilué suffisamment
pour devenir transparent.
Ça, c'est ce qu'on appelle le fond
diffus cosmologique.
Et c'est les premières lumières
qui ont réussi à se balader dans l'espace.
Et ça, on estime que c'était il y a treize
virgule 8 milliards d'années.
D'accord, et on ne peut pas voir au delà.
On ne pourra jamais voir au delà
parce que très au delà, il faudrait voir
avec autre chose que de la lumière.
Ça, c'est possible, mais pas avec
de la lumière, quelle qu'elle soit.
La lumière, ça ne marche pas.
Du coup,
on ne pourra pas voir au delà d'une sphère
de 13,8 milliards d'années
lumière de rayon pour réaliser.
Elle est plus grande encore parce qu'il
a continué à s'agrandir notre univers.
Mais dans l'idée, c'est ça
qu'on ne
peut pas voir avant la lumière
ait pu se propager.
Et quand vous avez montré le film avec les
les deux ou 3 millions de galaxies
et les endroits où il y en avait pas,
il y avait une boule.
Et cette boule, c'était la limite des 13,8
milliards d'années
lumière de propagation de lumière.
Ça, c'est la limite de ce qu'on
peut observer.
Oui, et si vous voulez aller
un peu plus loin
dans les théories qu'on a du big bang
aujourd'hui, pour remonter plus loin
encore, en théorie,
on peut remonter de 300 000 ans.
Après, on arrive sur ce qu'on
appelle le big bang.
Et là, on a un problème
parce que les équations d'Einstein
nous disent
qu'on ne peut plus les utiliser.
Donc soit les équations d'Einstein
correspondent à quelque chose de physique,
c'est à dire que c'est réellement
la naissance de l'espace et du temps
qui ont lieu à ce moment là,
304 20 000 ans
avant que l'univers devienne transparent.
Soit il y a autre chose qui s'ouvre
et qui continue
loin derrière, mais ça,
on n'a pas la réponse. Il nous faudrait,
il va falloir arrêter.
On ne peut pas aller vite.
Il nous faut ce qu'on appelle une théorie
de la gravitation quantique qui nous
permette de comprendre et le très, petit
et le très grand en même temps.
Alors je continue non,
on ne va pas pouvoir continuer parce que
on ne va pas y arriver.
Il y a deux questions.
C'est drôle, il y a deux questions
d'internautes, des habitués
de nos conférences sur Internet
tous les deux.
Dix questions pour la fin à votre invité.
Alors il y a une question pour la fin
qui dit si cela était possible,
qu'un instrument amélioration
ajouté Auriez vous James Webb ?
Télescope.
Et l'autre question
qu'est ce qui peut selon vous,
selon vous, Christophe encore surprendre,
Surprendre les astronomes aujourd'hui ?
L'amélioration du James Webb ?
Franchement, pour l'instant,
on en a pour dix ans
ou quinze ans de découverte
avec les technologies qui qu'il possède.
Si l'amélioration,
c'est que je remettrai deux
ou trois plus grands encore
pour récolter encore plus de lumière.
Mais technologiquement, c'est déjà
absolument extraordinaire que ce qui a été
fait, donc franchement, c'est pas mal.
Et ce qui pourrait surprendre
les astronomes,
c'est justement quand on tombe sur
des phénomènes qui n'étaient pas prévu,
qu'on voit par exemple
aussitôt dans l'histoire
de notre univers
des trous noirs aussi gros.
On se dit il manque,
il manque un truc, ça c'est génial et
dans les années à venir,
ce qui est super avec et c'est pas mal
comme question de fin.
Ce qui est super avec un télescope
comme James Webb, c'est que ayant
une technologie
qui nous permet de voir une lumière
pour l'instant pas extrêmement développée
par les autres télescopes,
aussi bien en tout cas,
cette lumière infrarouge,
ça nous permet trois choses
me permettre de résumer ce qu'on a vu.
La première, c'est
ça nous permet de voir
ces premières lueurs
qui étaient visibles et ne le sont plus.
Donc ça nous permet d'aller
voir plus loin que jamais.
Ça nous permet de remonter jusqu'aux
plus anciennes galaxies
potentielles, jusqu'aux premières étoiles.
Si on avait une sensibilité
plus grande encore,
ça nous permet
de traverser des nuages de poussière.
Ça nous permet de voir des nuages qui
émettent de l'onde des ondes infrarouges.
Ça nous permet de voir des étoiles naître
parce qu'elles émettent en infrarouge.
Ça nous permet de nous rapprocher
des trous noirs et ça permet,
à côté de chez nous, de relire
l'histoire potentielle des mondes.
On est en train, une fois de plus, de lire
en regardant
d'autres étoiles
l'histoire de la terre et du Soleil.
C'est génial
et ça nous permet de remercier Christophe
Gans pour cette belle soirée.
Merci beaucoup à vous.
Merci Maître
et merci à la lumière, à la technique,
à tout le monde.
Merci pour cette lettre d'amour.